ALAN ARCHULETA AT KANSAS STATE
BACKER BARGES BRADFORD COME BY
YELLOW CORTEZ THREE DALLY DODD
DURAZO EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALES
GROW HURTS BERG WESTERN HER
TADO JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED
LEYBA THE MON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S
MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN A TELEPHOTO
PAM PARSONS TINO ROSSI RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG QUAKE
OWSKI. WINNER WELL. MEMBERS OF
THE QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE ROLE IN IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING. IT WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BUT
SOONER OR LATER AFTER WHICH
WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO COME
REMAIN STANDING IN THE LEAD AND
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
LEVEL. GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL
GOD IN THESE DAYS OF DISTRESS
AND TURMOIL WE TURN TO YOU FOR
STRENGTH AND COMFORT IN OUR
SUFFERING AND GRIEF. DAILY WE
WITNESS YOUR GENEROSITY AND THE
COURAGE AND STRENGTH OF
FIREFIGHTERS WHO SEEK TO QUENCH
THE FIRES RAVAGING OUR STATE.
WE WITNESS YOUR LOVE AND CARE
IN THE COURAGE OF THOSE WHO
RUSHED TO HELP IN THE RECOVERY
EFFORTS FROM DEVASTATING
FLOODS. WE WITNESS YOUR HEALING
TOUCH AND THE DEDICATION OF
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WHO RISKED
THEIR OWN WELFARE IN THIS
CONTINUING COVERT PANDEMIC. WE
ARE IN ALL OF THE YOUNG MEN WHO
FEEL CALLED TO SERVE THEIR
COUNTRY TO THE POINT OF DEATH.
RATIONS GOD WE PRAY FOR THOSE
DISPLACED BECAUSE OF FIRES
FLOODS WARS AND DISEASE. AND WE
ASK YOU TO GIVE THEM THE
STRENGTH AND RESILIENCE TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES WITH
GREATER INTENTION. GREATER
CREATIVITY AND GREATER LOVE.
GIVE ALL OF US THE STRENGTH OF
PURPOSE OF THAT OUT OF THESE
TERRIBLE EVENTS. WONDERS OF
GOODNESS AND GRACE WILL EMERGE
TO BRING COMFORT AND HOPE. IN
THE MIDST OF SO MUCH SORROW. WE
ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
PLEDGING ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. PRODUCT.
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THREE
WAY SO BE PREPARED.
IN A WAY SO
WE HAVE PRIVILEGES FROM THE
FLOOR. FOR GEORGE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS TODAY. I CAN
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION WE HAVE A
VERY SPECIAL VISITOR VISITING
THAT THE SENATE TODAY TODAY
WERE VERY HONORED TO HAVE THE
GOVERNOR ELECT OF BACHA
CALIFORNIA MUDDY NOW THEY'LL BE
A LOT OF THE LAW. OR META.
BECAUSE SHE WAS OUR RECENTLY
ELECTED AND SHE EXPECTS TO
TAKE. OFFICE IN OCTOBER
VISITING FROM THE GREAT STATE
OF OPTICAL FORMULA. ALL OF US
ARE VERY FAMILIAR WITH OUR-
WITH OUR NEIGHBOR TO THE SOUTH
LIKE CALIFORNIA VERY IMPORTANT
STATE IN MEXICO- ONE THAT-
SHARES A LOT OF HISTORY. AND A
LOT OF THINGS IN COMMON WITH
OUR VERY OWN STATE AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER TO THE
CONFERENCE OF THE CALIFORNIANS.
AND MANY OTHER THINGS THAT WE
WISH TO TAKE ON WE SHARE. MANY
OF WONDERFUL OF. A QUALITIES
BUT WE ALSO SHARE A MANY
CHALLENGES AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH HER AND HER
MINISTRATION AND- THE
LEGISLATURE THAT YOU'LL WITH
HIM BACK ON THE PHONE SO
MEMBERS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING GOVERNOR ELECT BUT IN
OTHER. THANK YOU. YEAH MAYBE.
LORD KNOWS CALIFORNIA'S PLUS.
YEAH WE CAN THANK. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE SAY
WELCOME GOVERNOR. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
MESSAGE FROM THE GOVERNOR. THEY
WILL BE DOING READ MESSAGES
FROM THE FAMILY WILL BE DOING
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE KING RAT AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. NOW MOVE MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON THE MOTIONS RESOLUTE
RESOLUTION TO NOTICES. NOT
APPROACH HIM YOU RECOGNIZE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO. SURE TO ROLL
TWENTY NINE POINT ONE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE ITEMS FORTY
TWO SP. FIVE NINETY FOUR- ITEMS
TO AB. FIVE HUNDRED. THE FOUR
MEMBER MOTIONS THERE ARE
PERFORMANCE AT THE DENTIST AND
THEY WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED.
RIGHT. WE'RE COMING BACK TO
THIS AND SENATOR PROTEOME
ACTIONS MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH OBVIOUSLY CAUGHT UP IN
THE MOMENT OF OUR GUESTS WHO
ARE HERE TODAY- MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I AM REQUESTING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL ON SB
NINE BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
HAVE REVIEWED THIS LETTER SO
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SENATOR
HERTZBERG THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT HI PLEASE MOVE FILE
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT ONE BY ME
TO THE INACTIVE FILE AND SECOND.
FOR THE DESK PLEASE MOVE FILE
ITEM TO SEVENTY NINE THE SIMPLY
MEASURED TEN FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT TO THE
ACTIVE FILE THANK YOU SPECIAL
THANKS TO NOW THANK YOU. YEAH
YEAH RIGHT RIGHT SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
NUMBERS AT THREE QUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE FILE
NUMBER THREE EIGHT FIVE THAT'S
A B. TEN THIRTY FIVE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND MOVE IT TO
THE THIRD READING FILE. DOES
NOT THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT ON AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE FILE NUMBER. ONE
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR NINETY NINE.
TO THE INACTIVE FILE. BILLY
NOTED THANK YOU. EARLIER THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE
FINALIZED- TWO TWO NINE EIGHTY
FOUR OH TWO TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. THIS WILL NO. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER ACTIONS AT THE START.
THE OUR MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR DODD ARE YOU PREPARED.
YES MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
KNOW. MEMBERS MAY BE GETTING
TIRED OF ME GETTING UP AND
MAKING. ANNOUNCEMENTS LIKE THIS
BUT YESTERDAY MORNING- MY OTHER
SON AND HIS WIFE HAD R. TWELVE
GRAND CHILD. COULD CREDIBLY
HEALTHY BABY BOY SEVEN POUNDS
EIGHT OUNCES TWENTY TWO INCHES
LONG AND- WE'RE JACK I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE IT FOR A
WHILE I. I CAN'T ALTHOUGH I
CAN'T COMMIT TO THAT ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER. THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE WE'RE MOVING
TO IS. SECOND READING FILE
MA'AM COURT PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILLS. 1-326-500-3664
FIFTY ONE AND A FULL.
348-112-6820 NINE ASSEMBLY BILL.
896787 DEGREES WOULD BE
DIFFERENT. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. WE HAVE QUITE A FEW
ITEMS HERE I HOPE MEMBERS
ALREADY PREPARED TO TAKE THOSE
ITEMS UP FIRST UP IS FILE I'M.
SIXTY NINE. MADAM PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETY BY
ASSEMBLING BY THIS TIME THE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AN ACT
RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. JOURNALS AND YOU PREPARE.
GOT. KEVIN LATER IN GERMAN
SENATE THIS IS A COMMITTEE BILL.
THIS WOULD. I GUESS.
CONTEMPORIZE THE PENALTIES
ALLOWABLE. FOR THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT. VIOLATIONS. THE
TEN TWENTY TWELVE THERE WAS A
FIFTY DOLLAR ANNUAL FEE TO
COMMITTEES THAT HAD TO FILE
THESE REPORTS. THAT LIST TO PAY
THE MINISTRY COST FOR DOING
THESE THINGS. IF A COMMITTEE
FAILS TO PAY THE REQUIRED FEE.
THIS IN S. B. HELLO TEN TO TEN
OO ONE. IT REQUIRED THEN UP TO
THREE TIMES OR A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLAR FEE. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES IT THE COMMITTEE IS
REQUIRED TO PAY THE FIFTY
DOLLAR ANNUAL FEE THE SECTOR IT
WOULD BE DEFECTORS STATE. IF
THAT IS NOT TIMELY PAID.
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS WOULD
BE LEVIED. IT TRANSFERS
RESPONSIBILITY OF ENFORCEMENT
FROM THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION. THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THERE IS
AN ADDITIONAL. CROSS FILING
REFERENCED THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT INCLUDE I WOULD URGE AN
IDOL ON THIS COMMITTEE BILL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATES ON FALL
ITEM SIXTY NINE AB FIFTEEN
NINETY. KIND OF MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR YOU NATIONAL.
MANCHESTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ADKINS
FIVE EIGHTHS FIVE BECKER HI
PORGES HI BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM I PROTESTING I DALLY I
DONT. HI TORONTO HI ADNAN FIVE
GLAZER. HI CONSOLIDATES I GROW.
HI HURTS BURKE HI WITH SO. HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LIVE ON. THE MON HI
WIRE HI MELINDA'S FIVE MIN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I. OTERO ABODE
I CAN I PERSONS YOU KNOW. I
BROUGHT. HI RUBIO SKINNER I
STERN BERGER HI HI WORK I'LL
SPEAK FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI HI
CENTER NELSON MOVES A CALL NON
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE FALL
ITEM SEVENTY. ABC SEVEN FOUR
SIX CENTER ADMIN ARE YOU
PREPARED. ANNOUNCER TERRY
PLEASE RE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SAVANT IS AN ACT RELATING TO
ADOPTION. ZERO COMMENTS THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT A MEMBER TODAY
PRESENTING AB SEVEN FORTY SIX
ON BEHALF OF HIS FAMILY MEMBERS
ARE BONDED. THIS HAS TO DO WITH
THAT STREAMLINING THE PROCESS
FOR ADOPTIVE OR STEP PARENTS TO
BE ABLE TO COMPLETE THE
ADOPTION PROCESS WE KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A CUMBERSOME
PROCESS ESPECIALLY FOR OUR LGBT
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. THIS WILL
BE ABLE TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS AND GET MORE KIDS INTO
LOVING HOMES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IN G. NINE MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS FIVE
EIGHTHS. BACKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTESE I DALLY. GOD HI YOU'RE
AWESOME HI ADNAN I GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WEST SO. HER TADO.
HI JONES HI KIM LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON HI
WIRE. MELINDA'S MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. PHOTO OF BOTH. HI PAM I
POURED INTO YOU KNOW. I. ROSS I
REVIEW SKINNER. FIVE STERN I'M
BURKE I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. HI SENATOR GRAHAM MOVES A
CALL NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
THE FALL I DON'T EIGHTY FOUR.
AV TWO THREE TO. SOONER I KASKI
ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER AN ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES THROUGH
OUR CULTURE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT IN THE WORLD OF- OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLES ARIZONA IDAHO
AND UTAH HAVE RECENTLY ENACTED
LAWS THAT REQUIRED OUT OF STATE
VISITORS WHO WISH TO OPERATE
THERE- H. VIS IN THE STATE TO
PURCHASES OUT A STATE PERMIT.
EVEN IF THE VEHICLE OF
CALIFORNIA VEHICLES ARE
PROPERLY REGISTERED IN THE HOME
STATE IN THE MEANTIME THE
RESIDENTS OF ARIZONA IDAHO AND
UTAH GET TO COME IN THE
CALIFORNIA WITH THEIR- H. FEES
AND YOU CAN RECORD ON OUR
PUBLIC LANDS- STILL ENJOYING
THE BENEFITS THAT CALIFORNIA.
RECIPROCITY PROVISIONS PROVIDE
THIS MEASURE IS SIMPLY GOING TO
CORRECT THAT AND WILL SAY THAT
THE RESIDENTS OF ARIZONA IDAHO
AND UTAH IN ANY OTHER STATE
THAT REMOVES HIS RECIPROCITY
WITH CALIFORNIA HAS TO GET
THERE OUT OF. A STATE- H. P.
PERMIT NITROGEN I VOTE. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN
NINETEEN ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE. I
BACKER HI FORGES HI BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM I CORTESE FIVE
DALLY. GOD HI TORONTO BY ADMIN.
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HI
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HER TADO
I JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LLEVA I THE MON I MAGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF VOGUE I CAN
I FOURTEEN TO NO. HI RALPH I
RUBIO SKINNER I STERN AMBERG HI
HI WHAT CASKEY I WINNER. I WILL
HI. IN A ROW BECAUSE HE MOVED
TO CALL NUMBERS REMOVING THE
FILE ITEM NINETY TWO. SENATOR
LAMAR ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
ITEM SHIAS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAVANT AS AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE. SIR
LAMONT THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF SOMEONE OR
SURVIVE THIS DESPITE
MISCARRIAGES BEING A COMMON
OCCURRENCE THERE IS STILL A
HIGH DEGREE OF STIGMA
SURROUNDING MISCARRIAGES MANY
WOMEN ESPECIALLY BLACK AND
BROWN WOMEN FIND THEMSELVES IN
IRAQ IN AN ISOLATING GRIEVING
PROCESS THEIR EMOTIONAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL NEEDS OFTEN GO
UNMET. AS WE SEEK TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH AND
REDUCE THE ADVERSE OUTCOMES OF
PERSISTENT MATERNAL DEPRESSION
WE MUST ENSURE THAT
INTERPRETING C. CARE IS
CONSIDERED A PART OF POST
PARTUM CARE WHEN SCREENING IS
EITHER OFFERED OR PROVIDED ALL
WOMEN DESERVE QUALITY MENTAL
HEALTH INCLUDING ANY WOMAN WHO
HAS HAD HAS BEEN PREGNANT
REGARDLESS OF THE OUTCOME OF
THEIR PREGNANCIES. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WILL
EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH TO
INCLUDE INTERPRETANT SEE CARE
TO ENSURE THAT MOTHERS SEEKING
ASSISTANCE HEALTH CARE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS INCLUDE
WOMEN WHO EXPERIENCE
MISCARRIAGES THIS BILL WILL
HELP MAKE CURRENT LAW CLEAR AND
ADDRESS THE COMPLICATIONS OF
MEDICAL ISSUES THAT DEVELOP
DURING PREGNANCY ESPECIALLY
AFTER MISCARRIAGES OR
STILLBIRTHS OR ASSESS A WOMAN'S
MENTAL HEALTH. AND PHYSICAL
WELL BEING THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHERDISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FACE I
BACKER HI FORGES I BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY.
GOD HI THE RYZEN FIVE EGGMAN.
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HI
HURTS BERG I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO. HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LIVE ON HI THE MOON
I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM HI FORTINO. HI
RALPH I RUBIO SKINNER. HI STERN
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL HI. SERIAL MOM
MOVES A CALL NON MEMBERS
REMOVING ON THE FALL ITEMS
NINETY SEVEN. SUFFICE
ASSEMBLYMAN SYSTEM SIMPLY
PERSON IRWIN CENTER CENTER ON
BURGER YOU PREPARE YET SHE'S
RUNNING TO HIS TEST MAP
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AN ACT
RELATING TO VITAL RECORDS
CENTER ON BIRDS FLOWERS RICH
FAMOUS PRESENT MEMBERS EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY WON'T CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED KIND OF RECORDS
ACCEPT ELECTRONIC REQUEST OKAY
ACCESS CERTIFIED BY THE RECORDS
BIRTH MARRIAGE AND DEATH
CERTIFICATES GOOD BILL BOTOX.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NONE OF MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I
BASE HI BECKER FIVE FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD. ARTICLE BY ADAM
HI COURTESY I DALLY. DOT HI
TORONTO HI ADMIN FIVE LASER EYE
CONSOLIDATES. GROVE HI
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HURTADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER. LAYERED
HI LLEVA HI THE MON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN
I FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I
REVIEW SKINNER I STERN- BERG I
LIKE HOW SKI. NO WINNER I WILL.
HI SENATOR UMBERG MOVES A CALL
NUMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE FALL
ITEM NINETY EIGHT. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT CENTER
WAIVERS PREPARED FROM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES INTERLUDE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN SIGNED AB TWO SIXTY ONE
BY THEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN
WHICH ALLOWED STUDENTS TO
PETITION TO HAVE A SEAT ON
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT GOVERNING
BODIES WITH PREFERENTIAL VOTING
RIGHTS IN ORDER TO VOICE THEIR
OPINIONS. HOWEVER THAT BILL DID
NOT INCLUDE COUNTY BOARDS OF
EDUCATION AND CHARTER SCHOOL
GOVERNING BOARDS EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS BEFORE YOU
TODAY WOULD EXTEND THE PETITION
PROCESS TO ALLOW STUDENTS TO
PETITION FOR A SEAT ON COUNTY
BOARDS OF EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOL GOVERNING BOARDS WITH
PREFERENTIAL VOTING RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS CERTAINLY
DESERVED TO SAY THEY SAY IN
THEIR EDUCATION AND HOW IT IS
SHAPED. THIS BILL BY STUDENTS
FOR STUDENTS IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER ASSOCIATION AND
GENERATION UP AND IS SUPPORTED
BY THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S COMMITMENT TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL TO
CLARIFY THE INTENT OF A V.
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION IS NOW
NEUTRAL THEREFORE THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS I
DON'T. C. NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS FIVE
EIGHTHS. BECKER FIVE FORGES
BRADFORD HI BYRON HI CORTESE HI
DALLY. DODD I DRAW SO I
EXAMINED EYE GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO SORRY FOR
TOTTENHAM I JONES NO CAN WATER
I LAYERED I. LEIVA. I THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON NO A
SHOW ABOUT. TEN FIVE FOURTEEN
TINA HI RALPH I RUBIO SKINNER.
FIVE STERNE AMBERG ALL RIGHT I
LIKE HOW SKI HI WINNER I WILL
NOW. CYNDER LABOR MOVES A CALL
NOW MEMBERS REMOVE IT ON THE
FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED- A. B.
NINE THIRTY BY MISTER LEVIN
SENATOR RON BURKE IS REPAIRED
AROUND SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN AN ACT
RELATING TO EXCAVATIONS CERNER
OVER. FAMOUS PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AT NINE THIRTY
AUTHORIZE AND EXECUTE A RECOVER
ATTORNEYS FEES OR CLAIMS
ARISING FROM FULLY MARTIN
SUPPOSEDLY DAMAGE UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES BUT I. R. EFFICIENT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA. ATKINS
FIVE BABIES I BACKER. HI FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY. GOD I
TORONTO BY ADMIN FIVE GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HI GROSS. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO HI HER TADO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR.
HI THE MON I WIRE. I MELINDA'S
NO MAN. I NEWMAN. I NIELSEN I-
TELEVOTE HI PAM I FOURTEEN TINA
HI RALPH I RUBIO SKINNER. HI
STERN I'M BURKE I WAS ASKING I
WINNER I WILL. HI SENATOR
UMBERG MOVES A CALL NUMBERS
REMOVING ON THE FALL OUT OF ONE
TWENTY FIVE. MEASURED BY
SENATOR ASSEMBLYMAN MAYES
SENATOR OFFICE REPAIRMAN SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CALL- READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAZE AN ACT
RELATING TO SURFACE MINING
CENTER RALPH THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AS YOU
KNOW THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AS THE PRIMARY WHOLESALE WATER
SUPPLIER FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SERVING LOS ANGELES
ORANGE RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARD
DINO SAN DIEGO AND VENTURA
COUNTIES CHARGED WITH PROVIDING
RELIABLE SUPPLIES OF WATER FOR
NINETEEN MILLION RESIDENTS
BUSINESSES AND AGRICULTURAL
LANDS THE SURFACE MINING AND
RECLAMATION ACT CURRENTLY
REQUIRES THAT RECLAMATION PLANS
TO BE SUBMITTED AND APPROVED TO
EACH COUNTY WHICH CAN
INEVITABLY LEAD TO DELAYS IN
METROPOLITAN STABILITY TO
REPAIR AND RESTORE DAMAGED. TOO
MUCH WATER TRANSER FACILITIES
THIS BILL WILL AUTHORIZE
METROPOLITAN TO SUBMIT ONE
MASTER RECLAMATION PLAN FOR THE
REGULATED ACTIVITIES THAT OCCUR
ON ITS OWN LAND WITHIN ITS SIX
COUNTY SERVICE AREA. SUPPORT
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IN C. NINE MANCHESTER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BAIT. I
BACKER. HI OR JUST I BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM HI THREE FIVE
DALLY I DOG. I TORONTO HI
AIKMAN I GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH. HI HURTS BURKE I
WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MOON. HI WIRE. I MELINDA'S
FIVE MIN FIVE NEWMAN I NELSON I
A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM HI
FOURTEEN TO NO. I. ROSS HI
RUBIO SKINNER. HI STERN AMBERG
I LIKE HOW SKI HI WINNER I WILL.
HI ZEROTH MOVES THE CALL
NUMBERS REMOVED ON FILE EITHER
ONE TWENTY SEVEN ANOTHER
MEASURE VIA SOME AMAZING SOME
SENATOR MARKEY'S PREPARED AND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ALL ITEMS
ONE TWENTY SO. ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAZE AN ACT
RELATING TO IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS AND DECLINED THE
URGENCY THERE UPTICK BACK TO ME
DAILY. IN A REPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS PRESENT GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS- I RISE
PERCENT EIGHTY TEN TWENTY ONE
AM PRECIADO ALL THE HARD WORK
BY SIN REMEMBER MAZE. IT'S
SIMPLE AB TEN TWENTY WIND WOULD
COMMISSION A STUDY WHICH BY THE
WAY IS FUNDED IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WOULD FUND AND IT WOULD
COMMISSION A STUDY TO HELP
DETERMINE THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT'S GOVERNING
STRUCTURE. WHILE ALSO ENSURING
PUBLICLY OWNED A MANAGEMENT
SCHOOL SERVICE TO THE COACHELLA
VALLEY REMAINS IN PERPETUITY AT%
TODAY AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE
DISTRICT'S. REPAIR 60% LIVE
OUTSIDE OF THE DISTRICT'S
BOUNDARIES AND THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE. FOR
REPRESENTATIVES OF THEIR PUBLIC
UTILITY AGAIN FINDINGS AND
SECURED IN THE BUDGET FOR THIS
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I HAVE A- THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN CHINO AND
MINISTER TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOLLOW HIM FOR TWENTY
SEVEN. ALAN I ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS I BASE. BACKER HI FOR
JUST BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM HI
C. I. DALLY. FIVE DOT. ARE YOU
THERE ALSO HI ADMIN I. LASER I
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HER TADO
FIVE JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON HI
MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. OCHO VOGUE BY
PAN HI FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS
FIVE RUBIO SKINNER. HI STERN
I'M BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL HI. REMEMBER OUR
MUSICAL NUMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO FOLLOW ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE
MEASURED BY SOME LONG SENATOR
RALPH HE'S PREPARED AND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG AN ACT
RELATING TO PHARMACY SENATOR
ROTH THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THIS BILL ENABLES OUR
PHARMACISTS IN THE STATE TO
REMAIN PART OF OUR RESPONSE. TO
THE COVE IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND IT MAY OF A BACK.
PHARMACIST OF STEPPED UP TO
ASSIST IN CARING CAL. TO
PROVIDE ACTS TO BECAUSE ACROSS
THE STATE THIS BILL WILL X. FOR
BACKS AUTHORITY TO ALL VACCINES
APPROVED BY THE FDA FOR
CALIFORNIANS AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIED THAT PHARMACIST MUST
WAIT TO ADMINISTER VACCINES
UNTIL THEY HAVE RECEIVED A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND READ ON THE SIDE
OF. YOUR INJURY NINE MINUTES
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ADKINS FIVE
EIGHT FIVE BACKER. I FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ V. I. DALLY. DOT FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE MY GROWTH I HURTS
BURKE HI WAY SO. ONE HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MOON HI
WIRE. I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN I COULD
SHOW UP BOTH HI PAM. HI FORTUNE
TINO I. ROSS HI RUBIO SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNER. HI WELL. I. SOONER
THIS MOVES A CALL NOW WE'RE.
NEVER MOVED ON FOLLOWING A ONE
THIRTY ONE- HEY MEASURE BY SOME
CHANCE IN A WAY SO ARE YOU
PREPARED HE IS BEEN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAN AN ACT
RELATING TO CANNABIS. JERUSALEM
THANK U. S. PRESIDENT SENATOR
SENATORS- AB ONE TWO TWO TWO.
WOULD EXEMPT CANNABIS
BEVERAGES. FROM THE OPAQUE
PACKAGING REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY REQUIRED FOR ALL
EDIBLES. AND WOULD INSTEAD
AUTHORIZED CANNABIS BEVERAGES
TO BE PACKAGE IN A GLASS
CONTAINER. THAT IS CLEAR OR ANY
COLOR TO MEET THIS REQUIREMENT.
CANADA'S BEVERAGES ARE THE
FASTEST GROWING SECTOR IN THE
INDUSTRY BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
MANUFACTURERS FIND THEMSELVES
HAVING TO ABIDE BY PACKAGING
LANGUAGE THAT WAS DESIGNED FOR
EDIBLES AND SMOKEABLE PRODUCTS.
BY A. B. ONE TWO TWO TWO AMENDS
THE CURRENT LAW TO AUTHORIZE
CANNABIS BEVERAGES TO BE
PACKAGED IN A GLASS CONTAINER
THAT IS CLEAR ANY COLOR TO BE
DEEMED COMPLIANT. THIS BILL HAS
NOT POSITION IT HAS PASSED ON
CONSENT IN THE ASSEMBLY HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A
NOVEL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HINGING ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
BAIT HI BECKER HI PORGES HI
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I C. I.
DALLY I DONT. HI TORONTO HI A
GUNMAN HI LASER EYE CONSULTANTS
I GROW I HEARD SOME BURG HI
WEST SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN WATER I LAYERED I LABOR I
THE MON. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S
FIVE MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I
HAVE A TELEPHONE I PAM I
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I RUBIO
SKINNER I STERN NUMBER I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER. HI WELL. HI
THERE WAS SOME OF THE CALL NOW
MEMBERS REMOVED ON A FALL ITEM
ONE THREE TWO- M. MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLYMAN MEMBER DOLLY AND
PRESENTED BY SENATOR DOLLAR.
pASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLY AN ACT
RELATING TO HUNTING. CENTERED
ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MAYBE- FOR CHANGES A
MATE TO SHELL IN CURRENT LAW TO
REQUIRE RATHER THAN AUTHORIZE
THE DIRECTOR. OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE DFW TO
DECLARE TO FREE HUNTING DAYS
UNDER THE BILL AND A COKE AND
THE COMPANION UNLICENSED HUNTER
WHO HAS COMPLETED THE HUNTER
SAFETY COURSE WOULD BE ALLOWED
TO HUNT WITHOUT A LICENSE ON
THESE. FREE DAYS IF A K. F.
OKAY. COMPANION BY LICENSE
UNDER TWENTY ONE YEARS OR OLDER
WHO HOLD A VALID HUNTING
LICENSE. TO ENSURE. NECESSARY
SAFETY IN THE FIELD AVIATOR FOR
WOULD RESTRICT LICENSED HUNTERS
TO ONLY. BE ACCOMPANIED ONE
LICENSE SATURDAY TIME AND
REQUIRES THAT THEY ALWAYS
REMAIN IN CLOSE VISUAL AND
VERBAL CONTACT WITH THEM RECENT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN OUT AT THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WERE MINOR AND TECHNICAL AT THE
REQUEST OF DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO AID IN
IMPLEMENTATION THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SAYING ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE MY
BACKER HI FORGES I BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI
DALLY. I DONT FIVE DURAZO I
EXAMINE. HI BLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ HI GROSS. HI HURTS
BERG HI WITHOUT. HI HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER. GLARED I
LLEVA I THE MON. MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN HI NEWMANI
NIELSEN I A CHILL OF BOTH HI
PAM. I FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS I
RUBIO SKINNER I STERN- BERG ALL
RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. HI THE CENTER MOVES A
CALL NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY FOUR.
THE MEASURE BY ASSUMING GRACE
AND CENTER ON BIRCH HE'S
PREPARED MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SECRET MEDIA.
CENTER ON BOTH. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO ADDRESS ISSUES WITH
RESPECT S. B. THIRTY FIVE WHAT
IT DOES IT CLARIFIES THAT THE
THREE YEAR SHOT CLOCK FOR
DEVELOPMENT MODIFICATIONS
APPROVAL IS PAUSED- TOLD WHEN
THE CITY SUES A PROJECT. NUMBER
TWO IT SPECIFIES THE PROJECT
MUST ONLY COMPLY WITH THE
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS THAT WERE
IN PLACE WHEN THE PROJECT WAS
INITIALLY APPROVED AND NUMBER
THREE AB ELEVEN THIRTY FOUR
CLARIFIES HOW TO DETERMINE WHEN
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITY. ON THE
SITE HAS BEGUN HI RICHARD HI
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THE SIDE
OF. NINETY NINE MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS HI
FAITH I BACKER I FOR JUST I
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T. HI
COURTESY I DALLY I DON HI
TERRAZZO I EXAMINED EYE LASER
EYE GONZALEZ HI GROSS HI KURTZ
BURKE HI WAS SO HYPER TANTO. HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN
HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A
TELEPHONE HI PAM I PERSON TINA.
RALPH FIVE RUBIO SKINNER. HI
STERN AMBERG HI I Y. CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL HI. THE NUMBER OF
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS ARE WERE
MOVING ON TO FALL AT ONE THIRTY
SIX. A MEASURE BY HOW SOON CHOW
SOME WOMEN ARE TOO LISTENER
ARTILLERY PREPARED HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RE. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOW AN ACT
RELATING TO INFORMATION
SECURITY SOONER OR TOMORROW
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROTECT THE CYBER SECURITY OF
OUR STATE SCHOOLS CYBER
SECURITY THREATENS. THREATS ARE
COMMON REALITY TODAY AND BECOME
AN IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION FOR
ALL GOVERNMENTAL ANY AGENCIES
AND ENTITIES ESPECIALLY ABOUT
THE PANDEMIC THAT HAS SHIFTED.
MANY IN PERSON OPERATIONS TO
ONLINE. EIGHTY ONE FIFTY TWO
WILL ADDRESS THESE CYBER
SECURITY CONCERNS BY ALLOWING
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT TO
PERFORM SECURITY ASSESSMENTS AT
THE REQUEST. OF THE SCHOOLS THE
ASSESSMENT WILL BE CONFIDENTIAL
AND PAID FOR BY EACH AND EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THE SIDE OF. CURRENCY ON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I BAIT I BACKER. I PORCHES I
BRADFORD HI COME BY ADAM I
PROTECTING FIVE DALLY HI TODD.
FIVE TORONTO I A COMMON I
PLEASE SIR I CONSOLIDATE ARI
GROVE. I HEARD SPURRED HI WITH
SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE
MON I WIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO
FIVE ROCK HI RUBIO SKINNER.
FIVE STERNE AMBERG ALL RIGHT I
LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL
HI. SINNER ARCHULETA MOVES CALL
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON THE
FALLEN ONE THIRTY SEVEN AND-
MEASURE BISONS A SOLACE.
SENATOR HER TADO IS PRESENTING
SHE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL AT
NINE FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE AN ACT
RELATING TO TRIBAL GAMING AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
SIX MEDIALLY. SOONER TODDLE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FIVE SEVEN AS A
VEHICLE TO RATIFY THE TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACT ENTERED
INTO BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TWO INDIAN
TRIBES THE SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA
TOUCHY TRIBE AND THE MIDDLETON
RANCHERIA FORMAL INDIANS OF
CALIFORNIA. BRIEFLY I'LL SPEAK
TO THE AGREEMENT WITH THE TECH
TO TRY BECAUSE IT'S A CASINO IN
MY DENTIST IN MY SENATE
DISTRICT. FOR DECADES APACHE
TRIBE HAS BEEN A VALUABLE
PARTNER IN THE KING'S COUNTY
COMMUNITY. THE TRY PROVIDE
SCHOLARSHIP ASSISTANCE JOB
TRAINING AND ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS HEALTH AND WELFARE
ASSISTANCE AND OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES IN ADDITION THE
TROUBLE BE PROVIDING NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND GOODWILL
TO KINGS COUNTY THROUGH AN
INTER GOVERNMENTAL AGREEMENT.
THAT WILL BE PROVIDED OVER HALF
THE EXPENSES FOR MAINTENANCE OF
THE FIRE STATION IN SHORT THE
TRIP HAS BEEN THE DEFINITION OF
A GOOD NEIGHBOR. THE LANGUAGE
IN THE COMPACT TO SUBSTANTIALLY
THE SAME AS RECENT CONTACTS
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION ON
FILE AND ASK FOR AN I. BOAT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
DRIVE- YES- MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IS CHAIR OF THE SENATE
GEO I WANTED TO VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR THE RATIFICATIONS.
OF THE MIDDLETOWN AND SANTA
ROSA COMPACTS. THAT'S A OUT AND
ALSO POINTS OUT SYNERGY- HAD AN
INFORMATIONAL. HEARING ON THESE
COMPACTS LAST WEEK WHERE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. GAVE THE
DETAILED EX EX WIFE OF THE
TERMS OF THE COMPACT. I WANT TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY THANK
CHAIRMAN CISCO THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA. AND CHAIRMAN SIMON
OF THE SANTA ROSA TRIED. AS
WELL AS UNITED HERE FOR THEIR
WORK. OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS.
I HOPE YOU CAN ALL JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THESE CONTACTS.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND A VERY. CENTRE
HER TODDLER TO CLOSE. I RESPECT
LAST FOR MY OUT MANCHESTER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATTENDEES HI BASE.
I RECORD I PORCHES BY BRADFORD
I HAVE A I DON'T I CORTEZ E. I.
DALI I DON. HI THERE AWESOME I
EXAMINED HI GLAZER ICONS ALL AS
I GROW. HI HURTS BERG HI WITH
SO HI HER TADO I JONES. I CAN
LONGER HI FLARED HI FLAVA FIVE
THE MON HI WIRE HI MELINDA'S I
MEN FIVE NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. I A
CHILL OF BOTH HI PAM. FOURTEEN
TINA. HI RALPH HI RUBIO SKINNER
I STERN AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE
SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL HI.
INTERTIDAL MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
NOW REMOVED ON THE FALL I DON'T
WANT THREE EIGHT. THE ISSUE-
GAMING- SENATOR DOT ARE YOU
PREPARED. HE IS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY THE SSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION AN
ACT RELATING TO HORSE RACING
CENTER DOT MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC IS AWARE OF THE
ACTIONS. TAKEN BY THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
WHICH PROMOTES OPENNESS AND
TRANSPARENCY IN DECISION MAKING
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AFTER I BOUGHT. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE HERE IN CHINO AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ACTON'S HI
BABES HI BECKER. HI PORGES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T I
COURTESY I DALLY. I DONT FIVE
TORONTO I EXAMINED EYE PLEASER
I CONSOLIDATE I GROVE. FIVE
HURTS BERG I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I. LEIVA HI THE MON
FIVE MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S FIVE
MEN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TO
A BOOK HI PAM. HI FOURTEEN TINA.
HI RALPH I RUBIO INNER I STERN
AMBERG HI FLY CASKEY HI WINNER
I WELL I. SENATOR DODD MOVES A
CALL MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON THE FILE AND ONE FORTY SIX
MAJOR BY SEVENTEEN PRESENTED BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE. A FAMILY BELL
THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING AN ACT RELATING TO ENERGY
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE. EXPANDS LOW INTEREST
LOAN PROGRAMS TO FUND ENERGY
STORAGE AND TRANSPORTATION AS
RELIABLE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ARE YOU SURE A FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF A MAN CENTER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE I
BACKER. HI FORGES HI BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON'T I COURTESY I
DOLLY. I DONT I DRAW SO I
EGGMAN HI GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH ARE
YOU HURTS BERG I WEAR SO. HI
HER TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER
HI LAYERED I LLEVA. HI THE MON
I WHERE I MELINDA'S I'VE BEEN.
I NEWMAN I NELSON I WOULD SHOW
UP BOTH I PAN. HI FOURTEEN TINA.
HI ROB I RUBIO KENNER. FIVE
STERN I'M BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI IN ORDER TO
REMOVE THE CALL NOW MEMBERS
REMOVING ON THE FOLLOWING A ONE
FORTY EIGHT SENATOR LAYERED FOR
ZONING MEASURE ON BEHALF OF
CORNER HARGA SOONER OR LATER
HE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER
FOR BATH AN ACT RELATING T
COASTAL RESOURCES IN EARLIER
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE SRIPPS
INSTITUTION OF OCEANOGRAPHY AT
UC SAN DIEGO TO CONDUCT A
RESEARCH STUDY TO IMPROVE
COASTAL MONITORING CAPABILITIES
AND OBSERVATIONS NECESSARY FOR
THE STATE'S DEVELOPMENT OF A
COASTAL BLUFFS EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM. IT'S THE HOPE OF THE
AUTHOR TO EVENTUALLY HOWEVER
MANY WARNINGS FOR BLOOD
FAILURES ON OUR WEATHER APPS
MUCH AS WE DO FOR HIGH WIND
FLOODING OR HIGH SURF
ADVISORIES IT'S CRITICAL TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE IT'S
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT CUT
OFF THE ASSEMBLY FLOORNINE MINUTES SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I. ADKINS. BAYTEX I BACKER. HI
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE A
I DON'T. COURTESY HI DOLLY I
DONT. I DRAW. HI EXAMINED EYE
GLAZER EYE CONSOLIDATES FIVE
GROVE. HI HURTS BERG HI WITH SO
I HER TADO I JONES. I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR I THE
MON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN.
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TRAIL OF
BOTH HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO HI
RALPH I RUBIO. INNER I STERN
NUMBER HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE
WINNER I WELL I. DINNER LAYERED
MOVES A CALL CENTRE LIBERTIES
BACK UP TO BAT HE'S HERE NOW
FOR FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SIX ON
BEHALF OF SOME WOMEN MEN SHINE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY SIX BY-ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIN SHINE AN
ACT RELATING TO CIVIL LAW STIR
EARLIER- MISTER PRESIDENT THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE A NEW AVENUE
FOR VICTIMS OF FERTILITY FRAUD
TO PURSUE JUSTICE OR SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES I ASKED FOR AN I.
BOOK. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN
NINETEEN NINETY MOUNT SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS. BAIT HI
BECKER HI PORCHES I BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON'T. QUARTET THE
FIVE DAILY I DONT. I TORONTO BY
ADMIN I GLAZER ARE YOU
CONSOLIDATE I GROSS I HURTS
BURKE I WAS SO. HER TADO I
JONES. I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I LIVE ON I LIVE ALONE. HI WIRE
I MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM. HI FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS. I
REVIEW SKINNER. FIVE STERNE IM
BERG ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI.
I WINNER I WILL HI EARLIER
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM ONE FIVE
SEVEN A MEASURE BY ASSEMBLYMAN
ARAMBULA AND SENATOR COPIER WAS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEMBER
AROUND ILA AN ACT RELATING TO
RESOURCE CONSERVATION CENTER
CAREER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS ARRIVED TODAY 2% AB
FIVE FIVE NINE A BILL THAT ADDS
UNDER REPRESENTED VOICES TO THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY
BOARD. THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER IS
A KEY NATURAL RESOURCE THAT
BORDERS MY DISTRICT AND IT
HOLDS THE POTENTIAL FOR GREAT
PUBLIC BENEFIT UNFORTUNATELY
MANY IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE
LIMITED ACCESS TO GREEN OPEN
SPACES AND THE BOARD IS MISSING
VOICES REPRESENTING THESE
COMMUNITIES WHO COULD BENEFIT
FROM RIVER ACCESS THE MOST AB
FIVE FIVE NINE EXPANDS THE
BOARD TO INCLUDE A NEW SEAT FOR
TRIBAL NATIONS OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AS WELL AS A
SEAT FOR A YOUTH MEMBER THIS
BILL ALSO RECAST EXISTING SEATS
TO INCLUDE INPUT FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS WITHIN MADERA AND
FRESNO COUNTY. IT ALIGNS THE
OPERATION OF THE CONSERVANCY
WITH OTHER STATE CONSERVANCY'S
SUCH AS RE CLASSIFYING BOARD
PROCEDURES TO COMPLY WITH
BAGLEY KEENE OPEN MEETINGS ACT
THESE NEW VOICES IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY BOARD
WILL REFLECT THE REGION'S
DIVERSITY THE PARKWAYS
IMPORTANCE TO THE STATE AND THE
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE THAT
THAT LAND HOLES FOR THE
REGIONS- INDEED YOU INDIGENOUS
TRIBES. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU IN FOR DISCUSS
INVADE ON THIS ITEM. IN
NINETEEN ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS BASICS NO
BACKER. I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
HAVE A- HI CORTEZ HE I DALLY NO
DOT. FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATES FIVE
GROVE. HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI
HER TADO JONES NO CAMCORDER I
LAYERED I LABOR. HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A TRIO OF
BOTH NO PAM I PORTION TINA I
BROUGHT. HI RUBIO SKINNER FIVE
STERNE AMBERG ALL RIGHT HI WHAT
KIND OF SCARY FIVE WINNER. I
WILL NOW. THEIR CAREER MOVES
CALL MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FALL ITEMS ONE FIVE EIGHT
WE HAVE CENTER PAN FOR CERTAIN-
SEMINAL RAMBLA DOCTOR FOR
DOCTOR MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAM DEALER AN
ACT RELATING TO HATE CRIMES
DOCTRINE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SENATORS- RICE PRESENTS EIGHTY
SIX HUNDRED BY SIMMERING BELOW
WHICH PROTECTS OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL CIVIL RIGHTS BY
REITERATING CALIFORNIA'S
POSITION TO PROHIBIT CRIMES
AGAINST A PERSON COMMITTED
BECAUSE OF THAT PERSON'S ACTUAL
OR PERCEIVED IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THE FACSIMILE FORTY
FOUR MILLION IMMIGRANTS LIVE
AND WORK IN THE UNITED STATES
DESPITE A CLEAR PROTECTIONS FOR
THESE IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS
FROM HATE CRIME IN FEDERAL AND
INTERNATIONAL LAW THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE NOT ALWAYS
INTERPRETED PROPERLY IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN I AUTHORED SB SIX
HUNDRED WHICH AMENDED THE JESS
UNRUH CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE TO OUTLAW
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
CITIZENSHIP IMMIGRATION STATUS
AND LANGUAGE AB SIX HUNDRED
THIS BILL WOULD CONFORM
PROTECTED CLASSES IN CRIMINAL
HATE CRIME LAW WHAT THE CLASS
IS PROTECTED BY SB SIX HUNDRED.
INSURING IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS
DO NOT FACE HATE FACE
DISCRIMINATION WITHOUT REPRISAL
IS A KEY STEP IN SUPPORTING
THOSE ALREADY SUFFERING
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT FROM
THE PANDEMIC A. B. SIX HUNDRED
DOES NOT HAVE ANY FORM
OPPOSITION. I STRICTLY OSCAR
NIGHT BUT- THANK YOU FURTHER.
AND DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. HERE
IN C. NINE MINUTES PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ADKINS BABIES FIVE BACKER. I
PORCHES. BRADFORD HI BY ADAM I
CORTEZ C. FIVE DALLY. GOD I
DRAW SO I EGGMAN. GLAZER FIVE
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG I WENT SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I. LEIVA FIVE THE MON.
FIVE MCGUIRE ONE FIVE MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A
SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM HI PORTS
AND TINA. I. ROSS. I RUBIO
SCANNER. FIVE STERNE AMBERG HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER. I
WILL. HI PETER PAN MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS THAT WERE MOVED ON TO
FILE I DON'T ONE FIVE NINE A
MEASURE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGREE ARE CURRY PRESENTED BY
SENATOR CORTESE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FOURTEEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER AGAR CURRY AN ACT
RELATING TO WILDLIFE HABITAT
SENATOR CORTESE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUE CB SIX
FOURTEEN GENERATES FUNDING FOR
THE EXISTING NESTING BIRD
HABITAT INCENTIVE PROGRAM- THE
SCHOOL HAS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION ENJOYS WIDESPREAD
SUPPORT FROM A DIVERSE
COALITION. OF GROUPS
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS AND
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS AND
AGRICULTURAL REPRESENTATIVES.
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF EIGHT ON THE SIDE
OF. URGENCY NINE MOUNT SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS I FACE.
BACKER. I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM I PROTESTING HI
DALLY. DOT I THERE ARE SO I
EGGMAN I PLEASE SIR. I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
I JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I LIVE ALONE. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I GO TO A VOTE I PAN.
HI FOURTEEN TINA I ROTH I RUBIO
SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER ALL
RIGHT I LIKE OUR SKI I WINNER I
WILL. HI HI. THE NEW CORTESE
MOVES TO CALL NON MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM ONE SIX
FIVE IMAGE REVISE SOME REMEMBER
FRIEDMAN PRESENTED BY SENATOR
DRAWS OLD MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO BUILDING STANDARDS
SENATOR RUSSELL THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- BUILDING
CODES ARE INTENDED TO ENSURE
THAT RESIDENTS ARE SAFE IN
THEIR DRAWINGS. ENFORCEMENT OF
THESE CODES IS ESPECIALLY
CRUCIAL IN THE CONTEXT OF MULTI
FAMILY RENTAL DWELLINGS WHERE
TENANTS HAVE LMITED ABILITY TO
CORRECT HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES SOME LOCAL CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA PLACE RESTRICTIONS
OR PRECONDITIONS ON RESPONDING.
TO THOSE TENANTS TO
HABITABILITY COMPLAINTS FOR
EXAMPLE REQUIRING TENANTS TO
PROVE THAT THE PROPERTY OWNER
HAS BEEN UNRESPONSIVE OR THAT
THE TENANTS ARE CURRENT ON
THEIR RENT BEFORE. THE LOCAL
AGENCY WILL SEND OUT AN
INSPECTOR NONE OF THIS SHOULD
MATTER WHICH IS OPPOSED TO IT A
GOVERNMENT SUPPOSED TO ENSURE
THAT ALL DWELLING UNITS ARE
HABITABLE OR FREE OF LEAD
PAINT. EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
PROHIBITS LOCAL CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA FROM PLACING
RESTRICTIONS OR PRECONDITIONS
BEFORE RESPONDING TO HABIT
HABITABILITY COMPLAINTS WHEN
TENANTS ENTER INTO A CONTRACT
WITH THE LANDLORD IS COMMON
KNOWLEDGE VIA THE FIRST LINE OF
CONTACT. THE MOST DIRECT WAY TO
ADDRESS THE HABITABILITY
COMPLAINT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. C. NINE MOUNT SECTOR
PLEASE REACH ME PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS FIVE BABIES NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A I
PROTESTING HI DOLLY NO DOT HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN I LASER.
GONZALES I GROVE. NO HERTZBERG
I WITH SO. HI HER TADO. JONES
NOW WE CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON. I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN NO NEWMAN. I-
SHOW BOTH. NOTE NIELSEN NO PAN
HI FORTUNE TINA HI RALPH FIVE
RUBIO SKINNER. FIVE STERN
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL. NOW SOONER RATHER MOVED
TO CALL MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO A FILE ITEM. ONE
SEVEN THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AROUND BLOOD PRESENTED BY
SENATOR EGGMAN MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
NINETY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AROUND DELAY AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH DATA COLLECTION. SENATOR
GRAHAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT A BEACH TEN NINETY FOUR
BY. ASSEMBLYMEMBER AL RAM
REALLY HAVING TO DO WITH THE
COLLECTION THE TRAINING AND
THEN THE COLLECTION OF DATA AS
RELATED TO PEOPLE L. G. B. T.
PEOPLE DYING OF EITHER HOMICIDE
OR SUICIDE. IN ORDER THAT WE
MAY BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION AND THEN MADE BETTER
PREVENT THOUGH SAID DEATHS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN G. NINE MOUNT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FACE. BACKER I PORCHES I
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
CORTESE HI DOLLY. DODD WELL I
TORONTO I EXAMINED EYE PLEASER
I CONSOLIDATE. HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WEAR SO HYPER TANTO
HI JONES. I CAN'T LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MON HI
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. TOTAL OF BOTH.
HI PAM HI FOURTEEN TINA. HI
RALPH I RUBIO SKINNER. FIVE
STERNE AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI SURE IT
REMOVES A CALL MEMBERS NOW
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING ONE NINE
TWO A MEASURE BY AS SOON
GRAYSON AND PRESENTED BY
SENATOR PLANT MANAGER TERRY
PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT
RELATING TO AIR AMBULANCE
SERVICES AND DECLARING EVEN
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
SIX MEDIALLY. SENATOR GRAHAM
PERSONALLY FIND AIR AMBULANCES
IT'S A YES OR NO VOTE. ALL
RIGHT- ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
INNOVATE ON ITEM THAT. ON THIS
I DON'T KNOW OKAY. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHILE ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS BAIT I BACKER. I PORCHES
HI BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
PROTESTING I. DALI I DON. THERE
ARE SO. THEY'RE AWESOME HI
ADNAN I GLAZER. HI CONSOLIDATES
I GROVE I HURTS BERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE
MON HI WIRE. I MELINDA'S I MEN
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A TOTAL
OF BOTH HI PAM. ARE YOU FORTINO
HI RALPH HI RUBIOSKINNER I
STERN I'M BURKE I LIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER I WILL HI. SENATOR
RAND MOVES A CALL NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWO TEN WE
HAVE A MEASURE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COM LAGER AND PRESENTED
BY SENATOR COM LONGER. THAT'S
THE FIRST. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR CAN LONGER
AN ACT RELATING TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES. SENATOR COM ORDER
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I AM PRESENTING AB ONE EIGHTEEN
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH THE
COMMUNITY RESPONSE INITIATIVE
TO STRENGTHEN EMERGENCY
SYSTEMS. ALSO KNOWN AS THE
CRISIS ACT. AS A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WILL SUPPORT COMMUNITY
BASED RESPONSES TO LOCAL
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTEEN AS A REINTRODUCTION OF
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR FROM
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO THIS
BILL WE WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS
MEASURE THE BILL NOW PLACES THE
GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. EIGHTY ONE EIGHEEN
PASSED OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THERE IS
ALSO NO OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING C.
NINE YES CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I REALIZE
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL BUT I'D LIKE TO RECALL-
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED IN OUR
DISTRICT JUST RECENTLY WERE
OFFICER CAMPUS WAS SHOT AND
KILLED THE INDIVIDUAL THAT THEY
WERE DEALING WITH HE WAS KILLED
HIS WIFE HIS TWO SONS AND THE
ONLY REASON IS TWO DAUGHTERS
ARE ALIVE IS BECAUSE HE SKIPPED
OUT OF A BEDROOM WINDOW AND RAN
AWAY FROM THE HOUSE. I WAS
MENTALLY ILL AND TO SEND OTHER
THAN QUALIFIED LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT HAVE THE PROPER AND SAFE-
A TIRE TO BE ABLE TO A- PROTECT
THEMSELVES- OTHER THAN LIKE I
SAID THE BENNETT THE ISSUE WITH
OFFICER CAMPUS HE WAS. SHOT
WITHOUT. THAT NOT IN THE CHEST
AREA LET'S JUST SAY THAT- TO
SEND SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT
QUALIFIED TO DEAL WITH THAT
SITUATION WILL BE DETRIMENTAL
AND I THINK THAT WITHOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT SECURITY IN. THE
PAST THE FACILITY FIRST AND
SECURING THE SCENE FIRST SO
THAT MAYBE THEN AFTERWARDS WE
COULD SEND IN INDIVIDUALS WHO
COULD TALK AND YOU KNOW CANCERS
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO. YOU KNOW
COMMUNICATE WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE MENTALLY
ILL I THINK THAT WOULD BE ONE
THING BUT TO HAVE THEM BE THE
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE TO
ALLOCATE RESOURCES SO THAT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN DO THEIR JOB TO
SECURE THE SCENE IS NOT A GOOD
DEAL FOR ANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BACKGROUND. QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE THE OTHER
EXCEPT QUESTION YES. VERY MUCH
SENATOR MCCAIN I ASK I MEAN AS
A AS A LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKER WHO WOULD BE SOMEONE WHO
WOULD BE RESPONDING TO THIS IF
SUCH A PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED
CAN YOU LET US KNOW PLEASE IF
THE SITUATION WERE TO OCCUR A
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED THAT
PROGRAM WOULD BE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO HAVE
ALL THOSE ASSESSMENTS AND
PROTOCOLS ESTABLISHED. PRIOR
RIGHT TO SOMEBODY GOING OUT
THAT THERE WAS SOME KIND OF
TRIAGE ESTABLISHED WITHIN THAT
THAT THE APPROPRIATE IN PERSON
WOULD BE SENT OUT FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL A CALL IS THAT
CORRECT. YES SENATOR EDWIN THAT
IS CORRECT THE REALITY IS THAT
70% OF CALLS THAT COME INTO OUR
NINE ONE ONE DISPATCH ARE NON
VIOLENT NON CRIMINAL IN NATURE
OFTEN TIMES THEIR CALLS
REGARDING. PARKING NUISANCES
NOISE NUISANCES ON ISSUES
RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH
HOMELESSNESS- THEY ARE NOT
CRIMINAL THEY'RE NOT VIOLENT IN
NATURE THIS BILL EIGHT
ESTABLISHES A PILOT PROGRAM
WILL BE QUALIFIED COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WOULD BE
VETTED BEFORE THEY ARE
APPROVED. TO OPERATE INTO
COMMUNITIES THAT SEE THEY WOULD
BE WORKING IN CONJUNCTION WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT MOST OF THE TIME LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD PREFER NOT TO
HAVE TO RESPOND TO MANY OF THE
CALLS THAT THEY GET IN- THE
GOAL IS NOT TO HAVE ROGUE
INDIVIDUALS RESPOND BUT IT IS
TO. CONNECT TO APPROPRIATE
RESPONDED. TO THE CALLS AND
COMPLAINTS AND EMERGENCIES THAT
ARE COMING IN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE SENATOR. I
WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST SAY
THEN THAT I WOULD ENCOURAGE AND
I VOTE ON THIS AND I THINK ANY
TIME A CALL COMES IN BY THE
VERY UNFORTUNATE. OCCURRENCE
THAT HAPPENED WITH OFFICER
COMPOST IN A AND THE A SYMBOL
IN THE SENATOR'S DISTRICT. ANY
TIME A NINE ONE ONE CALLS IN
WITH SOMEBODY WITH A HISTORY OF
VIOLENCE WITH POSSESSION OF A
FIREARM THE APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE WOULD BE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN ANY.
PROGRAM STEPS LIKE THIS WOULD
HAVE THAT KIND OF TRIAGE BUILT
INTO IT AND I WOULD. ENCOURAGE
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DESCRIPTION OF THE BAIT
ON THE SIDE OF. NINETY NINE
CENTER KARL MARGARITA CLOSE YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU KNOW
THE REALITY IS ACROSS THE STATE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
DOING THIS WORK ALREADY. THEY
ARE WORKING VERY WELL- THEY ARE
NOT DIVERTING NEEDED RESOURCES-
AWAY FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THEY ARE SAVING LIVES THEY ARE
SAVING LIVES FOR THE FOLKS WHO
LIVE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES. AND
OFTEN TIMES THEY'RE SAVING THE
LIVES AND- TRAUMAS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT- AND OFTEN TIMES
THESE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WORKING WELL
AND IN CONJUNCTION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE. THANK YOU.
MANCHESTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM TO TUNE. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE NO
BACKER I FORGES HI BRADFORD I
HAVE A HI CORTESE I DALLY NO
DODD. I TORONTO BY EIGHT SEVEN
FIVE GLAZER. HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH NO HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO. I FURTADO I JONES.
FIVE CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA I THE MON I MAGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON. NO- TELEVOTE I PAN I
FOURTEEN TINA HI ROB I RUBIO
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG HI I
WAKE COUNTY I WINNER I WELL HI
THANK YOU SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM TWO THIRTY ONE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE KEEPER SENATOR
STONE BAND SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOR TWENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE AN
ACT RELATING TO STUDENT LOANS
SENATOR RICK OWSKI THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. HE BEAT UP
FOUR TO FOUR GROUPS WILL
REQUIRE PRIVATE STUDENT LOAN
LENDERS AND DEBT COLLECTORS TO
COMPLY WITH COMMON SENSE
EVIDENTIARY STANDARDS WHEN
SUING- BORROWERS SO WE KNOW
THAT PRIVATE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE IS NO
LONGER DESTRUCTIBLE IN
BANKRUPTCY AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IS CREDITORS ARE PURSUING THIS.
AGGRESSIVE LITIGATION KNOWN AS
ASSEMBLY LINE OF LAWSUITS
AGAINST BORROWERS AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE SUING THE WRONG PEOPLE
THEY GOT THE WRONG AMOUNT OF
DEBT THEY'RE NOT VERIFYING THE
AMOUNT THAT THE- DEBTORS ROW
THE DEBTORS FILED SUIT TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE. UC IRVINE'S
CONSUMER LAW CLINIC I REPORTED
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS 91% OF
THE BORROWERS DIDN'T EVEN HAVE
LEGAL REPRESENTATIONS OF THIS
BILL IS MODELED AFTER THE FAIR
DEBT BUYERS PRACTICES ACT.
WHICH HAS REDUCED THESE
UNSUBSTANTIATED LOSSES BY 57%
FOR CREDIT CARD DEBT AND WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE IT DONE ON PRIVACY.
LOAN TONIGHT VIRGIN ABOUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR OR BECAUSE
GUINNESS DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HERE IN JINAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON VOLUME TWO THREE ONE.
ALAN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BAIT.
NO BACKER. HI FORTUS NO
BRADFORD. I HAVE A I PROTECTING
FIVE DALLY NO DODD I TORONTO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
MY GROWTH NO HERZ BERG. I WAS
SO HI HER TADO. JONES NO ONE
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA
FIVE THE MON. HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN FIVE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A TROUBLED NO PAM I
FORTUNE TINO. I ROCK I RUBIO
SKINNER. I TURNED AMBER I WAKE
OUT SKI I WINNER I WILL HI
DETROIT BECAUSE HE MOVED TO
CALL MEMBERS NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FALL ITEM TWO THREE
EIGHT FILE I'M TWO THREE EIGHT-
BY SOMEONE WOMAN- WENT AHEAD
AND PRESENTED BY SENATOR LAMAR
ON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AN ACT
RELATING TO CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS GENERAL MOTORS
THANK YOU A RACE TODAY TO
PRESENT AT FOUR EIGHT BILL THAT
WILL UPDATE OUR STATE LAWS
INTERNAL GIVING TO ACCOUNT FOR
NEW ONLINE METHODS OF DONATING
WHAT PROVIDING CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS TO BOTH DONORS AND
CHARITIES. THIS BILL IS A
PRODUCT OF NEARLY FOUR YEARS OF
EFFORTS BY THE AUTHOR AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND
COUNTLESS STAKEHOLDERS TO
UPDATE CALIFORNIA LAW FOR THE
NEW REALITY OF ONLINE
CHARITABLE SOLICITATION EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT WILL OUT CHARITABLE
FUNDRISING PLATFORMS TO
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO EVERY
CHARITY TO REACH FAR BEYOND OUR
TRADITIONAL DONOR BASE WHILE
PROVIDING THE OVERSIGHT
CAPABILITIES FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ENSURE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD NOW MORE THAN
EVER MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
HAVE TURNED TO THE INTERNET TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO OUR LOCAL
CHARITIES AND THEY DESERVE TO
HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT THEIR
DONATIONS IS ARE HAVING. AN
IMPACT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ITEM. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER.
OR DEBATE ON. THE SIDE. HEARING
TO NINE MINUTES PLEASED THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BASE NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
BETTER LIFE FOR TESTING HI
DOLLY NO DODD. I TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I LASER I CONSOLIDATE I
GROW NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO
HYPER TANTO I JONES NOPE CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I. LEIVA. I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN. HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A CHOKE NO PAN I.
FOURTEEN TINA. I. ROSS I RUBIO
SCANNER I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL KNOW.
IN A ROOM MOVES A CALL NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FALL
AND TWO FOUR FOUR WE HAVE
SENATOR ALSO FOR SOME REMEMBER
SANTIAGO AND SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE SENATOR
RUSSELL THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT WILL
ALLOW ADULT CHILDREN TO ADD
THEIR DEPENDENT PARENTS OR STEP
PARENTS TO THEIR HEALTH CLEAR
CARE PLAN. ON THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET THIS BILL DOES NOT APPLY
TO EMPLOYER SPONSORED PLANS
THIS BILL WILL SAVE FAMILIES
MONEY ON HEALTH CARE COSTS AND
PROVIDES A GREAT OPTION FOR
MAKE STATUS FAMILIES OR
FAMILIES WITH A DISABLED PARENT
WHO DOESN'T QUALIFY FOR SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ARRIVAL. SHARE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM HEARING AND SEEING ON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA. I
ADKINS FIVE EIGHTHS. NO BACKER.
I PORCHES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
I DON'T. HI COURTESY HI DOLLY
NO DOT. I- ALSO I ADMIN FIVE
GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE FIVE
GROVE. NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI FOR TIDO HI JONES. NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR HI THE
MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO
MAN. NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO OTOBO
NO PAM HI FORTUNE TINA I
BROUGHT. FIVE RUBIO GAINER I
STERN NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO SENATOR RAZA
MOVES A CALL NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO FIVE
ONE. WE HAVE A MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD PRESENTED
BY SENATOR LARRY HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY LEASE CALL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD
AN ACT RELATING TO FORESTRY
CENTER LURK MR PRESIDENT- THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE A PROGRAM FOR
THE STATE TO PLAN MANAGE AND
IMPLEMENT FORCE RESTORATION TO
FORMALIZE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AUTHORITY AGREEMENTS BETWEEN.
THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT 57% OF CALIFORNIA
FORCE LANDS ARE OWNED AND
MANAGED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THIS EXPANDS THE
GOOD NEIGHBOR AGREEMENT PROCESS
ESTABLISHES PRIORITIES AND WILL
ACCELERATE THE PACE AND SCALE
OF ECOLOGICALLY BASED FOREST
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE. I ASKED FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF IT ON
THIS MEASURE. IN NINETEEN
NINETY MINUTES AFTER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FACE.
BECKER HI FORGES I BRADFORD ON
I HAVE I GOTTA I PROTECTING I.
DALI I DON. FIVE TORONTO HI
ADNAN I. LASER. I CONSOLIDATES
FIVE GROVE. I HURTS BERG HI
WITHOUT. HI HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
THE MON I REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT
SHOW A VOGUE. HI PAM HI FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH I RUBIO SKINNER I
STERN I'M BERG HI FIVE WHITE
HOUSE E. I. WINNER. I WILL I.
SIMILAR MOVES A CALL NUMBERS
ARE MOVING ON TO FOLLOW HIM TO
FIVE FIVE A MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLYMAN LOH PRESENTED BY
SENATOR FORTINO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW AN ACT RELATING TO DRIVER'S
LICENSES. AND YOU KNOW THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE WOULD ALLOW
THE DMV TO ESTABLISH RECIPROCAL
DRIVER'S LICENSE AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
FOREIGN COUNTRIES UNDER THIS
BILL THE DMV IS EMPOWERED TO
WAIVE THE BEHIND THE WHEEL
DRIVER EXAM FOR A PERSON WITH A
DRIVER'S LICENSE. FROM CERTAIN
FOREIGN NATIONS IF CONDITIONS
ARE MET THIS AGREEMENT WILL
IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH KEY COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD AND ALSO
PROMOTE ECONOMIC COOPERATION
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
COUNTRIES TEXAS MASSACHUSETTS
AND WASHINGTON ALREADY HAVE
SIMILAR AGREEMENTS IN PLACE.
AND BY OPENING THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR NEW COUNTRIES TO CREATE
RECIPROCAL AGREEMENTS NEW
ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS WILL BE
EXEMPT FROM BEHIND THE WHEEL
PORTIONS OF THE DRIVING EXAM
THERE IS NO REASON CALIFORNIA
SHOULD CONTINUE TO COMPLICATE
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE PROCESS.
FOR FOREIGN NATIONALS ON A
PERSONAL NOTE WHEN I VISITED
KOREA SEVERAL YEARS AGO I MET
WITH THEIR COUNTERPARTS FOR
THEIR DMV AND THEIR POLICE.
OPERATIONS TO TALK ABOUT HOW
THEY ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT DRIVERS
TRAINING AND I WAS IMPRESSED
WITH THAT EXPERIENCE AND SO IN
CONFIDENCE I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION VERY ON THIS MEASURE.
SENATOR BOARDS WHICH. QUESTION
FOR THE- FOR SPONSOR. SENATOR
POINTINGWE TAKE A QUESTION I
WILL TAKE A QUESTION THROUGH
THE CHAIR THROUGH THE CHAIR ON
DO WE HAVE A LIST OF COUNTRIES
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN REVIEWED
TO SOME DEGREE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE COMPARABLE TO
CALIFORNIA'S STANDARDS. THAT
LIST WOULD BE COMPILED BY DMV
THIS IT GIVES THEM THE ABILITY
TO LOOK AT THOSE STANDARDS- SO
WE HAVEN'T PICKED THE COUNTRY'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS LETTING THE
DMV DECIDE WHO'S APPLE THAT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING BUT- THEY
DON'T HAVE ONE JUST YET IS THAT
CORRECT I DON'T THINK THEY'VE
GENERATED A LIST YET BECAUSE
THE BILL HAS BEEN PASSED. OKAY-
I THINK IT IS COULD BE TERRIBLY
HELPFUL- COULD BE- RIGHT WITH
PROBLEMS YES BUT I THINK THIS
COULD BE HELPFUL- ESPECIALLY AS
OTHER COUNTRIES. HAVE- ASTRID
IF NOT STRICTER- DRIVING
STANDARDS IN CALIFORNIA BUT I
THINK THIS COULD BE VERY
HELPFUL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSIONOR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF SENATOR ALSO. NO OKAY
ALL RIGHT SINGAPORE JAN WAS
ELECTED CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I VOTE. I'M SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I. ADKINS FIVE BABIES
NO BACKER. HI FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM. HI
COURTESY I DALLY NO DOG. HI-
AWESOME I EGGMAN. GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO I JONES
NOPE CAN'T LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR HI THE MON I REQUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S KNOWED MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A TWO AGO. HI PAM HI
FOURTEEN TINA HI RALPH I RUBIO
INNER. I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WELL NO.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL SIXTY A MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN PRESENTED
BY SENATOR NEWMAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNT BERMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO VOTER
REGISTRATION SOON AND THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT A B. SEVEN
NINE SIX ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARC BERMAN. A.
B. SEVEN NINE SIX SIX TO
IMPROVE AND REFINE THE
CALIFORNIA NEW MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM TO ENSURE ITS CONTINUED
SUCCESS AND EFFECTIVENESS NEW
MOTOR VOTER HAS MADE
REGISTERING TO VOTE OR UPDATING
REGISTRATION EASIER FOR
ELIGIBLE VOTERS WHEN COMPLETING
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND STATE
IDENTIFICATION CARD
APPLICATIONS. THE PROGRAM HAS
PLAYED AN INSTRUMENTAL ROLE IN
CLOSING REGISTRATION GAPS AS
WELL AS IMPROVING THE ACCURACY
OF VOTERS MAILING ADDRESSES
WHICH IS CRUCIAL TO INCREASING
ACCESS TO VOTING BY MAIL.
DESPITE THE SUCCESSES AND
CHALLENGES WITH MODERNIZING THE
MOTOR VOTER REGISTRATION
PROCESS LIMIT THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS A. B. SEVEN
NINETY SIX ADOPTS FEDERAL MOTOR
VOTER TIMELINES FOR TIMELY
TRANSMITTAL OF VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION FROM
THE DMV TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. AS WELL AS CODIFYING
BEST PRACTICES FROM THE ONGOING
LEGAL SETTLEMENT INCLUDING DATA
REPORTING ON PROCESSING TIMES
TRAINING AT DMV AND SECRETARY
OF STATE STAFF AND MAINTAINING
COORDINATORS OF THE DMV AND
SECRETARY OF STATE TO MONITOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL AND
STATE MOTOR VOTER LAWS. A. B.
SEVEN NINE SIX WILL ENSURE THAT
THE PROGRESS MADE UNDER A NEW
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM WILL
CONTINUE WHILE KEEPING
CALIFORNIA'S VOTER ROLLS
ACCURATE AND UP TO DATE I
RESPECT THE YES OR NO VOTE
TODAY. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OF EIGHT ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
CENA AND MANN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ADKINS HI BABES.
BASED NO BACKER. I FORTUS NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A ITEM ID
PROTESTING I DALLY NO DODD. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN I. LASER FIVE
DOLLARS HI GROSS NO HURTS BERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO I JONES
NO KEN WALKER I LAYERED I LABOR
I THE MON HI MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S. NO MAN. HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A CHARTER OAK. PAM
FIVE PERSONS YOU KNOW. HI RALPH
I RUBIO SKINNER. FIVE STERNE
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER.
I WILL. WELCOME NOW A JOB OPEN
NO. SOONER NEWMAN MOVES TO CALL
MEMBERS OUR MOVEMENT ON THE
FALL ITEM TO NINE FEET FILE I'M
TWO NINE EIGHT A MEASURE BY
SOMEONE MEMBER BLOOM AND
PRESENTED BY SENATOR WILK AS HE
PREPARED HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. AT SOME LEVEL
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AN ACT
RELATING TO ANIMAL HEALTH- WHAT
FLOORS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM I RISE TO
PRESENT A B. TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
THE CALIFORNIA. PET BLOOD BANK
MODERNIZATION ACT WHICH I AM
THE PRIMARY AUTHOR CO AUTHOR OF.
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE IN
THE NATION THAT HAS THESE
CLOTHES COLONIES WERE DOGS ARE
LOCKED UP TO AS MANY AS TWENTY
THREE. OUT OF TWENTY FOUR HOURS
A DAY. AND THEN PERIODICALLY
BLOOD DRAWN FROM THEM- THIS
SYSTEM IS NOT ETHICAL. AND IT'S
NOT EFFECTIVE- WE'VE HAD WE'VE
HAD ALL KINDS OF DOGS DIE
BECAUSE OF LACK OF PLASMA- THIS
BILL WILL TRANSITION US IN. TO
A MORE ETHICAL WAY TO SOURCE
BLOOD WHICH IS WHAT THE FORTY
FORTY NINE OTHER STATES DO
WHICH IS PEOPLE VOLUNTEERED TO
BRING THEIR DOGS AND TO HAVE
THE BLOOD DRAWN. AND IT'S GOING
TO INCREASE SUPPLY AND IT'S
GOING TO BE MUCH MORE HUMANE
WAY TO. TREAT ANIMALS SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN EIGHTEEN- AND-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI I. ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS I FACE I BACKER I FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T LIFE FOR TESTING I DALLY.
I DON. I TORONTO I ADMIN FIVE
LASER EYE CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH I HEARD SEBERG I WAS SO.
I TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR. HI THE MON HI
WHERE. I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO- TROUBLE I
PAN I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I
RUBIO SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I
WHITE HOUSE V. I. WINNER I WILL
HI. SENATOR WHAT MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM THREE NINETEEN THE
MEASURE BY SIN REMEMBER BENNETT
SENATE BY SENATOR HER TADO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT AN
ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES.
SOONER TO OUT OF THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT OF
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH LACK BEHIND
THEIR PEERS AND HEALTH AND
EDUCATION OUTCOMES AND FOOD
SECURITY. WHILE TRANSITIONING
INTO ADULTHOOD WITH A LOOK AT
THE TOOLS AND SUPPORT THEY NEED
TO TRY TO THRIVE THIS WAS
FURTHER EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC AB SIX SEVEN FOUR
CODIFIES AN EXISTING PRACTICE.
WITHOUT CREATING ADDITIONAL
WORK OR FOR COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICE WORKERS. SIMPLY
REQUIRING THATYOU TRANSITION
OUT OF FOSTER CARE PROVIDED
WRITTEN INFORMATION REGARDING
THE POTENTIAL CALFRESH
ELIGIBILITY RECENT AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS CHAPTER IN OUR ISSUES
WITH EIGHTY FIVE FOUR SIX. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED A NO NO VOTES
AND RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I S.
RESPECTFULLY FOR AN IPO. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. YOU'RE IN
C. NINE MINUTES AGO- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS I BASE. FIVE BECKER I
FOR JUST I. BRADFORD I HAVE A
ADAM I PROTESTING I DALLY I
DONT. I TORONTO I EXAMINED EYE
LASER EYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE
FIVE HURTS BERG I WENT SO. I-
TIDO. I JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR I WILL MOAN I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. HI A
TELEPHONE HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO
HI RALPH I RUBIO SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL HI. INTERTIDAL
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS ARE
REMOVED ON THE FALL ITEM THREE
TWO ONE FIVE NINE THREE TWO ONE
A MEASURE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAN SHINE PRESENTED FOR THEM
SIR TERRY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIN SHINE AN
ACT RELATING TO ELDER AND
DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE. SENATOR
HERTZBERG THANK YOU THIS
MEASURE AUTHORIZES CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION FOR MANDATED
REPORTS RELATING TO ELDER OR
DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE TO BE
SHARED WITH LOCAL CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THUS
ALLOWING THESE AGENCIES TO
BETTER INVESTIGATE ANY SUCH
INSTANCES AS FEAR I VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS I DON'T. THREE NINE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ADKINS
HI BABES HI BACKER. HI FORGES I
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I C. I DALI
I DONT. I ALSO I PLAY. I
CONSOLIDATES I GROSS. FIVE
PARTS BERG HI WEAR SO I HER
TADO I JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I PLAYED BASS. HI THE
MON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN
HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A CHILL
OUT THOUGH. HI PAM I FOURTEEN
TINA I BROUGHT HI RUBIO INNER I
STERN AMBERG I WAKE OUT SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI IN ORDER TO
REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING TOO FAR I DON'T
FILE ITEM THREE TWO TWO THE
MEASURE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING
PRESENTED BY SENATOR WIENER I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE RE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG AN ACT
RELATING TO JURIES OONER
WINNER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
BECAUSE AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO-
WILL IMPLEMENT A PILOT PROGRAM
CALLED THE QUOTE BE THE JURY-
PROGRAM IN SAN FRANCISCO WHERE
LOW TO MODERATE INCOME JURORS I
WILL BE COMPENSATED- AT ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER DAY FOR
JURY SERVICE- THIS PILOT WAS
DEVELOPED THROUGH A
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIP. IN
SAN FRANCISCO OVER PUBLIC%
DEFENDER'S OFFICE DA'S OFFICE
THE BAR ASSOCIATION OF SUPERIOR
COURT- AND OUR TREASURER'S
OFFICE- IT'LL BE ENTIRELY
FUNDED THROUGH PHILANTHROPIC
FUNDS- RAISED BY THE SAN
FRANCISCO FINANCIAL JUSTICE-
PROJECT OUR COLLEAGUE THIS
PILOT PROGRAM WILL BE VERY
USEFUL- AND HELPING US- I'D
FIND A WAY TO DIVERSIFY OUR
JURIES- TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT PRECLUDED FROM
JURY SERVICE- BECAUSE THEY
SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD TO DO SO I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK RIVAL. ANY
FOR THIS INVADE THE SIDE. HERE
IN CHINO IN MANCHESTER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I BASE I PARKER FIVE
FORTUNES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
ITEM ID FOR TENNESSEE HI DOLLY.
I DON. I TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI
PLEASE- HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LABOR I THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MIN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A TURBO HI
PAM. HI FOUR TWENTY NINE. HI
RALPH I RUBIO KINNER. FIVE
STERN I'M BERG RIGHT HI WORK
OUT SKI I WINNER I WILL. HI.
SENATOR WINNER MOVES TO CALL
MEMBERS THAT WAS OUR LAST ITEM
ON THE SEVENTY THIRD READING
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS RESOLUTIONS I'M
GOING TO DO A JOURNEY IN MEMORY.
AND I ASKED MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR IT IS WITH HEAVY HEARTS.
THAT I MAKE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT
TODAY AND TOMORROW THE SENATE
WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR ACTIVE
DUTY MILITARY PERSONNEL ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. WHO
TRAGICALLY DIED LAST WEEK IN A
SUICIDE BOMBER ATTACK OUTSIDE
OF KABUL AIRPORT IN
AFGHANISTAN. THIRTEEN TOTAL
MILITARY PERSONNEL WERE KILLED
ALL SERVING OUR COUNTRY AND
FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH ONE OF
THE LARGEST HUMANITARIAN- LIVES
IN MODERN HISTORY. SENATOR
MELINDA'S WILL BE EVENTS IN THE
FIRST OF THE FOUR JOURNEY AND
MEMORIES TODAY. MORNING
HONORING CORPORAL HUNTER LOPEZ
A LOT CONTINUE LOOKING INTO.
LOOKING TO I'M SORRY AND IT
WILL BE HERE FROM- OTHER
SENATORS TOMORROW SENATOR
MELINDA AS WE KNOW THAT THE
LOPEZ FAMILY IS WATCHING THE
SESSION TODAY. PLEASE SEND OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF US HERE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE CENTER
MELINDA'S THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF UNITED STATES
CORPORAL HUNTER LOPEZ WHO WAS
TRAGICALLY KILLED IN A
TERRORIST ATTACK IN KABUL
AFGHANISTAN. HUNTER WAS ONLY
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD HE WAS THE
SON OF RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
CAPTAIN HERMAN LOPEZ AND DEPUTY
SHERIFF ALICIA LOPEZ. CORPORAL
LOPEZ GRADUATED FROM LOOKING AT
THE HIGH SCHOOL IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. AND IT WAS AS A
CHILD WHILE STILL IN HIGH
SCHOOL THAT HUNDRED DEVELOPED
HIS DESIRE TO PROTECT OTHERS.
SO AS SOON AS HE WAS OLD ENOUGH
HE BECAME A RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
EXPLORER SCOUT IN SEPTEMBER TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN HE CONTINUED
IN THAT POST UNTIL HE GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL. AFTER
GRADUATION HUNTER ENLISTED IN
THE UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS
AND WAS ASSIGNED TO THE SECOND
MARINE BATTALION FIRST MARINES
STATIONED AT CAMP PENDLETON.
THEY WERE KNOWN AS THE
PROFESSIONALS THE SECOND MARINE
BATTALION FIRST MARINES HAVE A
STORIED HISTORY. FOR THOSE WHO
ARE OT FAMILIAR THIS UNIT WAS
PART OF THE ASSAULT ON
GUADALCANAL WHERE THEY DEFENDED
AN AIRFIELD IN NINETEEN FORTY
TWO. AND IN OKINAWA IN NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
IN. NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE TO
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT THIS UNIT
RECEIVED A PRESIDENTIAL UNIT
CITATION WITH ONE SILVER AND
FOUR BRONZE STARS FOR ITS ROLE
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR. SO IT
IS FITTING THAT CORPORAL LOPEZ.
WHO KNEW FROM SUCH A TENDER
YOUNG AGE THAT HE WAS PUT HERE
ON THIS EARTH TO PROTECT OTHERS
WOULD BECOME PART OF SUCH AN
ELITE UNIT. CORBULO PREZ WAS
PLANNING TO FOLLOW HIS PARENTS
FOOTSTEPS AFTER SERVICE IN THE
MARINE CORPS AND HE INTENDED TO
JOIN THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
THIS PAST FRIDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL
PLAYERS FROM HUNTERS IN. EXCUSE
ME. THIS PAST FRIDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL PLAYERS FROM HUNTERS
ALMA MATER LOOKING INTO HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE HIS SISTER TRINITY
IS A SENIOR PROBABLY CARRIED
AMERICAN FLAGS ONTO THE FIELD
IN HIS MEMORY. HUNTER'S PARENTS
SHARED THE FOLLOWING WITH ME
ABOUT THEIR BEAUTIFUL SUN.
HUNTER WAS A HAPPY GOOD ALL
AMERICAN KID HE ALWAYS SEEMED
MORE MATURE THAN KIDS AROUND
HIM AND WE WOULD OFTEN SAY
HUNTER HAD AN OLD SOUL. HE
LOVED TO PLAY SOCCER HE LOVED
TO WATCH ALL THE STAR WARS
MOVIES UNTIL HE COULD RECITE
JUST ABOUT EVERY LINE INTO THE
BACKGROUND STORIES OF EACH
CHARACTER. HUNTER LOVED HIS
BROTHER ALLEN AND HIS SISTER
TRINITY. AND WOULD DO ANYTHING
TO PROTECT THEM. HE ALWAYS
ENCOURAGED THEM IN THEIR SCHOOL
WORK SPORTS IN ALL THEIR
ENDEAVORS. HUNTER HAD A WAY OF
CONNECTING WITH EVERYONE HE MET
TEACHERS FRIENDS AND CO WORKERS
WERE OFFERING OFTEN INQUIRE
ABOUT HUNTER AND ASK HOW HE WAS
DOING. HE ALWAYS SEEM TO LEAVE
A VERY LASTING IMPRESSION. AS A
TEENAGER IT WAS APPARENT TO ALL
HUNTER WAS COMMITTED TO LIVING
A LIFE OF SERVICE HE THRIVED IN
THE PUBLIC SERVICE ACADEMY AT
THE LOOKING TO HIGH SCHOOL AND
ONCE HE JOINED THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S EXPLORER PROGRAM.
HUNTER VOLUNTEERED FOR ALL
EVENTS NO MATTER HOW TIRED OR
HOW CHAOTIC HIS SCHEDULE WAS.
SOMETIMES IT ASKED THE FAMILY
TO ADJUST PLANS IN ORDER FOR
HIM TO MAKE AN EVENT. AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL HUNTER JOINED THE
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS AND
BLOSSOMED EVEN MORE. HE ENJOYED
TRAINING THE WORKING OUT IN
PERFECTING HIS CRAFT. BUT HE
ALWAYS MADE HIMSELF AVAILABLE
TO HIS PEERS AND ESPECIALLY TO
THOSE WHO NEEDED HELP. AS A
STUDENT AND EXPLORE AND AS A
MARINE HUNTER VOLUNTEERED TO
HELP HIS NEIGHBORS HIS
COMMUNITY AND FRIENDS AND HE
WOULD NOT HAVE HAD IT ANY OTHER
WAY. HE WAS DESTINED TO LIVE A
LIFE OF SERVICE AND DIED
PROTECTING VULNERABLE CHILDREN
FACING AN UNCERTAIN FUTURE.
THEY SAY ONCE A MARINE ALWAYS A
MARINE AND HUNTER WILL FOREVER
BE A PROUD AND HONORABLE
MARINES. THE LAST PART OF THE
MARINE CORPS HYMN. SAYS. I'M
NOT GOING TO SING IT. HERE'S
HEALTH TO YOU AND TO OUR CORE
WHICH WE ARE PROUD TO SERVE IN
MANY OF STRIFE WE FIGHT FOR
LIFE AND NEVER LOST OUR NERVE.
IF THE ARMY AND THE NAVY EVER
LOOK ON HEAVEN'S SCENES. THEY
WILL FIND THESTREETS ARE
GUARDED. BY UNITED STATES
MARINES. I ASK THAT WE JOURNEY
IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR MELINDA AND WE SEND
OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO THE
LOPEZ FAMILY AND WE TRULY
HONORED TO SERVICE OF CORPORAL
HUNTER LOPEZ. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW BREAK FOR
LUNCH MEMBERS MUST BRING THEIR
LUNCHES TO THEIR OFFICE OFFICES
PLEASE NOTE GATHERING WE WILL
RETURN TO SESSION AT TWELVE
THIRTY SHARP. AND WILL WORK TO
FOLLOW UNTIL FIVE THIRTY PM
TODAY SO WE WILL TAKE A BREAK
FOR LUNCH AND WE'LL SEE YOU
BACK AT TWELVE THIRTY.
MEMBERS
WERE GONNA GET BACK TO BUSINESS
OUR FIRST ITEMS AFTER OUR-
EXTENDED LUNCH WILL BE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS CENTER
ALERT WHEN YOU'RE READY. WE
HAVE THREE ITEM SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY ONCE MA'AM
SECRETARY. NO NO DENTAL RECORDS
ARE READY CENTER ALERT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUR FINAL ITEM
SEVENTEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF SUZANNE MARTINDALE SENIOR
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION. AND
INNOVATION PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT SHE WAS SENIOR
POLICY COUNSEL IN WESTERN
STATES LEGISLATIVE MANAGER
CONSUMER REPORTS SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JULY FOURTEENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSIONS OR DEBATE
ON THIS APPOINTMENT. HERE IN C.
NINE MOUNT SECRETARY CALL
ROLLING FILE I'M SEVENTEEN.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS BAIT.
BACKER FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM. QUARTET THE HI
DALLY. DOT. FIVE ZERO ZERO.
EGGMAN I LASER. TEN DOLLARS I
GROVE. HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HER
TADO HI JONES. CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LABOUR I THE MON.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S MAN. I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BUT SHOW
BOTH HI PAM I PERSON TINO. HI
RALPH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG HI I BREAK OWSKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL. SUCH A
VOGUE NO. SOONER OR LATER MOVED
TO CALL NEXT UP MEMBERS THIS
FALL ITEM. EIGHTEEN MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF DARNELL
GREASE B. TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION MR GRIZ VIA SERVED
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TRANSFORM
SINCE TWENTY TWENTY PRIOR TO
THAT HE WAS THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY DEVELOPMENT RESEARCH AT
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION ASSOCIATION.
FROM TWENTY ELEVEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY THE APPOINTMENT WAS
APPROVED AT THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE HEARING ON AUGUST
EIGHTEENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AUTOGRAPH. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE I'M SENATOR NEWMAN. AT
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I HAVE
THE PLEASURE OF SERVING AS THE
SENATE'S EX OFFICIO MEMBER TO
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
AND WORKING WITH MISTER GRIGSBY
WHO IS DOING A WONDERFUL JOB- I
STRONGLY URGE AND I'VE- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
FORM. IN NINETEEN NINE AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
FIVE EIGHTHS.
BACKER IN I.
NEWMAN I NELSON. WHAT TROUBLED.
PAN HI FORTINO I BROUGHT I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I'M
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSA
MEMBERS. BAYTEX HAVE I EVER.
GLAZER I HERTZBERG I WENT SO I
MCGUIRE I NIELSEN OCHO BOTH.
STERN. PORGES I DON'T KNOW.
LOCAL EARLIER MOVES A CALL NOW
MEMBERS WERE DEALING WITH FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF ERIC
HEINZ TO THE GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION MR HEINZ SPENT
TWENTY YEARS AS A TEACHER FOR
THE PITTSBURG UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BEFORE SERVING AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. HIS
APPOINTMENT WAS APPROVED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL
EIGHTEENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT. IN
NINE AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS FIVE BATES NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD. HI COME BY
ADAM HI CORTEZ THREE FIVE DALLY.
NO DOT I TORONTO I HATE WHEN I
LASER. I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG I WENT SO.
HI HER TADO. HER TADO HI JONES
NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I.
LEIVA. I THE MON I WIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO PAM
I FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS I RUBIO.
HI SKINNER BY STERN I'M BERG I
RECOUNT SKI I WINNER I WILL. NO.
FIVE THIRTY MILLS NINE NO POINT
MINUTES CONFIRMED. THE MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO. UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE HAVE A NUMBER I AM
SIR WE WILL LIKE TO GET
THROUGH- FIRST STARTING WITH
FILE ITEM THIRTY SOONER DELHI
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP S.
B. SEVEN OH NINE HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY. YOU MAY RECALL.
SENATE BILL SEVEN OH NINE BY
SENATOR DALLY AN ACT RELATING
TO FORESTRY AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE I'VE SEEN TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SURE DOLLAR.
MEMBERS BILLS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE TECHNICAL IN NATURE
AMENDMENTS ASK FOR MY BOAT.
MEMBERS THIS IS OLDER FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING UNIONS
RECALL ON THIS ONE ONE MOMENT
SIR WITH. ALL RIGHT- I'M SORRY
WE'RE GONNA CALL ROLE IN THIS
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL ON
THE URGENCY AND ON THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. BOUNCER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FACE I FACTOR. FIVE
PORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE I DON'T
I COURTESY FIVE DALLY I DON. HI
ALSO I EXAMINED EYE LASER EYE
GONZALEZ I GROSS I HURTS BERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADOI JONES.
I CAN LONGER. LAYERED I LIVE ON
I LIVE ALONE I WIRE I MELINDA'S.
I MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I
TRIED BOTH HI PAM I FORTINO HI
ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN
I'M BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL I AM SERVED HER
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
PORCHES. YOUR CAM AUGER I STERN.
ALL RIGHT HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I WAS
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FALL I'M THIRTY ONE
SURVEYS ARE YOU PREPARED CHIA'S
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR BATES AN ACT RELATING
TO SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
THANK YOU- MR PRESIDENT ARE
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WAS AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY TO
CLARIFY HOW THE INFORMATION
WILL BE DISCLOSED ON FACILITY
WEBSITES THAT HAS PASSED
THROUGH BOTH HOUSES WITHOUT A
SINGLE NO VOTE. I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HINGING ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I. ADKINS.
EIGHT HI BECKER. I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I DIANA HI CORTESE I
DALLY I DONT. I TORONTO I
EXAMINED EYE LASER EYEGONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO
HYPER TANTO I JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI
THE MON. HI WIRE I MELINDA'S I
MEN. I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN I GO
TO A BOOK. HI PAM I FORTUNE
TINO I BROUGHT HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN. AMBERG I'M HI
FI CASKEY I WINNER I WILL. HI
MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE CALL OUT
TO MEMBERS. ATKINS GORGEOUS
GROVE I STERN. WHEN A MOBILE.
AUGUST THIRTY SEVEN R. AS A
NATION ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
SINCE THEN CERTAINLY MEMBERS
MET AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NOW MEMBERS REMOVING ON TO
FOLLOW ITEM THIRTY TWO. SENATOR
RALPH COMMITTEE HE'S READY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY SIX BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS IMPRESSIONS SENATOR
OFF THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THIS
IS THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE'S ANNUAL
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP BILL BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. HE SENT ME A
MOMENT'S CLARIFY THE EXPERIENCE
REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY FOR
LICENSURE AS A PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY REPLACE A REFERENCE
TO THE APPROPRIATE FEE CHARGE
FOR RE EXAMINATION FOR A
GEOLOGIST APPLICANT AND OTHER
TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS I
DON'T. HEARING SINGING ON MOUNT
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO. ALLEN'S
HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS SPACE I
BACKER HI FORGES. HI BRADFORD
HI BY ADAM I CORTESE I DALLY I
DONT I TORONTO HI ADMIN I.
LASER HI CONSOLIDATES I GROW.
HI HURTS BERG HI WEST SO. HI
TANTO I JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I PLAY THEM I LIVE
ALONE HI WIRE. HI MELINDA'S I
MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A
TROUBLE BOTH. HI PAM I PORTANT
GENOME HI RALPH I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG HI MY
COSTING FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBERS.
ATKINS I STERN. PRICE THIRTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO THE SAME LIMITS
ARE CONCURRED IN NON MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY FOUR SENATOR SKINNER
SHE'S REPAIRED MADAM SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT
BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING SOONER
SOONER. THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
MADAM FOR MISTER PRESIDENT
THAT'S B. H. IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IT EXTENDS THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF SB THREE
THIRTY WHICH GREENLIGHTS
HOUSING PERMITS THAT ALREADY
MEET EXISTING LOCAL ZONING
RULES WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE SIDE
OF. HEARING TEEN NAINA MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE I'M THIRTY FOUR. ALAN
FIVE ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I
FACE. BACKER HI BORDERS.
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI FOR
TESTING. I DALLY. DOT I TORONTO
HI AIKMAN I LASER NO GUNS
ALLAH'S I GROW. HERTZBERG HI
WITHOUT FIVE HER TADO I JONES.
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LABOUR.
I LIVE ALONE HI MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON TOTAL OF BOTH I PAM FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS. HI RUBIO
I SKINNER HI STERN ON BERG I
WAKE COUNTY. FIVE WINNER I WILL
NO I'M SIX THREE PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. BATES NO FOR
JUST. DALLY GROVE. JONES
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY KNOWS THREE THE SIMILAR
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
NUMBERS NOW MOVING ON TO FALL
I'M THIRTY FIVE R. SENATOR DODD.
HE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL FIFTY
TWO BY SENATOR DODD AN ACT
RELATING TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
SENATOR DOG GREAT BILL NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
MEASURE. URGENCY NINE OZ THIRTY
NINE AND KNOWS IT ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
AND- NOW MOVING ON TO FALL I'M
THIRTY SIX SENATOR GLAZER CAN
YOU TOP THAT- MA'AM SECRETARY.
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL SIXTY
BY SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY OF
THEIR APPS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENIOR GUARD FOR
THE CELL AND THEN THE DATA
NERDS THE ASTRONAUT. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS I DON'T. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BAIT I
BACKER. FIVE FOUR JUST NO
BRADFORD R. I HAVE I GOTTA I
CORTESE I DALLY I DON. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. I WAS SO. I HER TADO
I JONES. NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR. HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
BOTH I PAN. HI FOURTEEN TINA HI
RALPH HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG HI HI BY CAL SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBER. MELINDA'S
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY FOUR NOS
ZERO ON THE URGENCY OF. I'M
SORRY I WAS THIRTY FOUR MEDALS
FOR ON THE URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY
FOUR NOS FOUR ON THE SEMI
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND-
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. SENATOR
NEWMAN ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT ITEM HE IS MOUNT SECRETARY
YOU MAY AGREE SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR NEWMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS
SENATOR NEWMAN. TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS I GO PLEASE. ALL
RIGHT- IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THAT I
DON'T. WHATEVER THAT ITEM WAS-
ANYWAY LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. ALAN.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE. BACKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
COURTESY I DALLY. DOT HI
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WISH SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES NO CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I FOURTEEN TINA. I.
ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN
I'M BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO I'M SECTOR.
PLEASE CALL HELP TO MEMBERS.
BASICS NO. PORGES NO DALLY.
GROVE NO MELINDA'S. STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS SIX THE
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON NOW
TO FALL ITEM THIRTY NINE BUT
SOONER WHY BECAUSE HE- HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ. THAT ABOUT FIVE
THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI AN ACT RELATING TO
CONSUMER DEBT SOONER OR COSTLY
ASSEMBLY MEMON SERVE REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION FROM ALL FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING A NINE MINUTE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS HI
BABES HI BECKER I FORGES.
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I COME BY
IT- I CORTESE I DALLY. I DONT I
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE ARI GROWTH HI HURTS
BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LABOR HI THE MON I MEAN WIRE. I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM
I FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG HI HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER. I WILL HI. OWN PLEASE
CALL THAT'S A MEMBER. PORCHES
STERN. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT MILLER
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND NOW MEMBERS
REMOVE IT ON THE FILE I DON'T
FORTY WE SEE SENATOR LAYERS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR LAYERED
AN ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS. AN
EARLIER WHY THIS BILL IS BETTER
THAN DOGS SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ALL RIGHT
AND I SEE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SITE ON. SEE NON MEMBERS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THIS MEASURE. C. NINE HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE COULD
BE HEARD IN. NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL I'M FORTY ONE SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY MARY. AT THE FIVE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT. CENTER HERZBERG
THANK YOU THIS WAY JACK TO COST
SAVING GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY
MEASURE AMENDMENTS THESE SIMPLY
CLARIFY PRIORITY OF LIENS
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE SIDE OF THE MEMBERS THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON FILE I'M FORTY ONE.
HE EARNED SCENE NINE HOURS
THIRTY NINE. KNOWS ZERO THE
SIMILE MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
AND- NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM FORTY THREE WE
HAVE A DOG. MAJOR HE'S READY
MADAM SECRETARY MARY SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR
DODD WHO ACT RELATING TO WATER
RESOURCES. SYNDERGAARD WHEN
YOU'RE READY. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. OKAY WELL STATED- ANY
SCRATCHES OR DEBATE ON THIS I
DON'T. KAREN SINGING ON MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE I'M FORTY THREE. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA. HI AT KINS. BASED
NO BACKER I PORCHES HI BRADFORD
HI I HAVE A I DON'T I
PROTECTING FIVE DALLY. DOT HI I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN EYE LASER EYE
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES. I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MON HI MCGUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT I NIELSEN. NO A SHOW OF
OAK HI PAM I FORTINO I. ROSS. I
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
I WAKE OUT SKIING I WINNER I
WILL HI. I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL OUT TO MEMBERS AT KENS
FIVE. BALLY. GROSS NO STERN. I
THIRTY FOUR NOSE FOR THE SIMPLY
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR
BECKER AND SHE HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ
AND ABOUT SEVEN SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR BACKER AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR BOOKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS SAID
THIS IS THE WORKFORCE
INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY ACT YOU
MAY RECALL THIS IS THE FIRST
BILL THAT I PRESENTED AND-
AFTER MUCH HAZING. AND A REVOTE
IT DID PASS WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO NO VOTES AFTER A
BRIEF AMENDMENTS IT IS BACK
FROM ASSEMBLY ARE STRICTLY
ASKED FOR YOUR FIVE A- FOR.
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. YOU'RE INSANE
NINE MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING. A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
MEASURE. HEARING C. NINE OZ
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE THE SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW ON TO FILE
ITEM FORTY FIVE SENATOR CORTESE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY BY
SENATOR CORTEZ SEE AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL FINANCE.
SENATOR CORTESE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- PLEASE PRESENT THE
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FOR CONCURRENCE
IT'S RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
WHATSOEVER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'LL VOTE. HE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ARE DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE I LIKE TO
DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THE FACT
THAT WITH ALL THE MONEY THAT WE
SPENT ON LOCAL HOUSING
PROJECTS. AND TO TRY TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS HOMELESSNESS HAS
INCREASED EVEN WITH BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THROWN OUT OF IT BY A
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
I SUPPORT BILLS THAT WILL HELP
PEOPLE GET OFF THE STREET BUT I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO SERIOUSLY
LOOK IN JANUARY WHEN WE COME
BACK ABOUT BILLS THAT WERE
REALLY WORK OR LOOK AT THE
RESOURCES THAT WE'RE GIVING TO
PEOPLE OR ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE NOT HELPING US PREVENT-
EVEN STABILIZING THE HOMELESS
POPULATION- THE- THE- THE
HOMELESS. TRAGEDY THAT WE HAVE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE BASICALLY SINCE TWENTY
TWENTY WITH INCREASED A HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
HOMELESSNESS SINCE WE'VE BEEN
THROWING MONEY AT THIS SO I
THINK WE REALLY NEED TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE SERIOUSLY AND I
AGAIN SUPPORT THIS BILL WHAT I
WOULD LIKE SOME. M. SERIOUS
DISCUSSIONS TAKING PLACE NEXT
YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE
SIDE ON. HERE IN C. NINE CENTER
COURTESY WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FACE HI BECKER. I PORCHES. HI
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DALLY. DOT I
TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER. I
CONSULTED HI GROSS I HEARD
SPURRED BY WEST SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LLEVA I THE MON HI MACQUARIE-
I MELINDA'S I MEN. HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM
I FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS I RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG HI I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
HI. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
APPS A MEMBER. DALLY HI STERN
ALL EYES THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE CINNAMON ARE CONCURRED IN A
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION GONNA
MOVE TO A FALL ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
THE SENATE THIRD READING ON FOR
SENATOR BORDERS ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM HE IS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE PRESIDENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR GORGEOUS
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA FARMER
AND FARMWORKER MONTH SOONER
BORDERS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES AS CHAIR OF THE
SENATE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION FIFTY FOUR TO
RECOGNIZE CALIFORNIA FARMER AND
FARMWORKER MONTH. OCTOBER WAS
SELECTED AS CALIFORNIA FARMER
AND FARMWORKER MONTH BECAUSE
IT'S THE END OF THE HARVEST
SEASON FOR MOST OF THE STATES
FOUR HUNDRED PLUS SPECIALTY
CROPS AS WELL AS THE TIME THE
CALIFORNIANS IN CONSUMERS
THROUGHOUT OUR NATION BEGIN TO
SELECT FOOD WINE AND FLOWERS
FOR HOLIDAY CELEBRATIONS IT'S A
GREAT TIME TO REMIND OUR
CITIZENS A CALIFORNIA PRODUCES
50% OF THE NATION'S PRODUCE
LEADS THE NATION SUSTAINABLE
DAIRY PRODUCTION IT IS THE
OVERALL LEADING. AGRICULTURAL
STATE IN THE NATION. CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRY A VITAL OF OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY. THE AREAS OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND FOOTHILLS
THAT I'M PROUD TO REPRESENT ARE
SOME OF THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IN THE WORLD
IN CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS AND
RANCHERS ARE STEWARDS OF TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ACRES. OF LAND
STATEWIDE. CALIFORNIA IS THE
NASCENT NATION'S LARGEST
PRODUCER OF AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS PROVIDING ONE THIRD OF
THE VEGETABLES TWO THIRDS OF
THE FRUITS AND NUTS IN THE
UNITED STATES. OUR FARMERS AND
FARM WORKERS PROVIDE
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION MEALS
A DAY SERVED IN SCHOOLS HOTELS
AND RESTAURANTS SPURRING OUR
STATE'S TOURISM INDUSTRY. THE
FOOD PRODUCERS FARM WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIANS WORKING IN OUR
SUPPORT OF INDUSTRIES HELP FEED
OUR NATION AND MEMBERS. OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
DURING THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND STEPPED UP TO
ENSURE THEY WERE MEETING THE
HIGH DEMAND FOR FOOD IN OUR
STORES. FARMERS ALSO DONATE AN
ESTIMATED A HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION POUNDS OF NUTRITIOUS
FOOD ON AN ANNUAL BASIS MAKING
THEM A VITAL PART OF OUR
STATE'S FOOD BANKS.
CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS AND FARM
WORKERS PIETER STATE TRACK
TOURISTS. AND SUPPORT ONE POINT
TWO MILLION JOBS IN TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE BILLION IN
TOTAL GENERATED REVENUE FOR
CALIFORNIA. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY IN ORDER
THESE HARD WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN.SO NEXT TIME YOU TRAVEL
THROUGH THE STATE AND SEE FIELD
SPANNING AROUND. THINK ABOUT
THE FARMERS AND FARMWORKERS
WORKING TO KEEP FOOD ON YOUR
TABLE IN AT YOUR LOCAL MARKET.
I'M PROUD TO BE JOINED BY THE
MEMBERS OF THEIR CULTURE
COMMITTEE FROM SINGER SELENA
STOCKTON IN CONTRA COSTA. ON
THIS RESOLUTION COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR FURTADO. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF S. R. FIFTY FOR
RECOGNIZING FARMER AND FORMER
PER MONTH FOR MANY OF US AND
OUR CONSTITUENTS- WERE
SHELTERING IN PLACE THE STATE'S
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY WORK
HAND IN HAND WITH RETAILERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS TO ENSURE A STABLE
FOOD SUPPLY. THIS WAS THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES THE
SERVICE AND SACRIFICE DURING
THIS TIME I RESPECT PLANS FOR
AN IPO. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THE SIDE ON.
SENATOR BALLET. THE CENTER DOWN
HERE FOR. OUR I GUESS MAYBE THE
ONLY FARMER ON THE FLOOR KING
IT IS MIKE TURNED ON- HEY JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS A
FARMER MYSELF- AS WE ALL HAD
SOME VERY WONDERFUL PEACHES THE
OTHER DAY I WAS GOING TO STAND
WITH THE REST OF ARMS AND THE
FARM WORKERS TO- COLLECT AT
WORK IN THE FIELDS WORK HARD
EVERY DAY EVEN TO THE PANDEMIC
HAVE BEEN WORKING TO SUPPLY
GOOD SAFE FOOD FOR CALIFORNIANS
SO I STAND IN- SUPPORT OF SR
FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
TO RISE AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR RAISING THIS ISSUE OF BOTH
THE FARMWORKERS AND THE
FARMWORKER COMMUNITY I THINK
THE BEST WAY HAVING BEEN A
FORMICA FROM WORKER WHOLE
FAMILY WERE MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS THE BEST WAY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE WHAT
THE FARM WORKERS DO EVERY DAY
BY BEING THERE UNDER THE HOT
SUN OR OTHER KINDS OF WHETHER
IT BY MAKING SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE REAL. OPPORTUNITY IN
THIS COUNTRY TO RAISE THEIR
FAMILIES IN A DECENT WAY GET
THE WAGES AND HEALTH CARE THAT
THEY DESERVE GET THE HOUSING
THAT THEY DESERVE AND THAT
SHOWS- UP MORE THAN WORDS WHAT
THEY REALLY NEED AND WANT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. IN JUNE NINE SENATOR
BORDERS WHICH ELECTRICALS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL AND
SECONDARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IN
NINETEEN NINE OZ THIRTY NINE
KNOWS IT ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
BACK TO THIS ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. WE HAVE FILE ITEM
SIXTY SIX. BY SENATOR BYRD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER
DISSENTED BY SENATOR BACKER
HE'S PREPARED MEN SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
TEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS SERVER GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS CLIMATE SCIENTISTS
AGREE THAT SOCIETY MUST PREPARE
FOR ZERO CARBON FUTURE AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR UR
DESIGN PROFESSIONALS ARE
PREPARED FOR THIS A NEW.
REALITY AS WELL. CURRENT
CONTINUING EDUCATION FOR
COVERING ARCHITECTS IS LIMITED
TO DISPEL THE ACCESS WHICH
MEANS MANY PROFESSIONALS HAVE
LITTLE OR NO EXPOSURE. TO
STRATEGIES FOR REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE ARCHITECTS
COMPLETE FIVE HOURS. ZERO NET
CARBON. THAT TREND CONTINUED
EDUCATION PER TWO YEAR LICENSE
RENEWAL CYCLE- IT COMES FROM
THE ARCHITECTURAL COMMUNITY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SOON SOON ON MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
I'M SIXTY SIX. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS I FACE. BACKER HI
FOR JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM
I FOR TESTING I DALLY NO DODD.
I DURACELL HI EGGMAN I BELIEVE
HER I CONSOLIDATE HI GROSS NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO I HER TADO I
JONES NO CAMEL OWNER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA. HI THE MON I MCGUIRE
I MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO A TRUCK
BOTH HI PAM. FOUR TWENTY NOW.
I. ROSS I REVIEW. I SKINNER HI
STERN NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER HI WELL I. I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
BATES NO GORGEOUS NO. MELINDA'S
PAN STERN. HIGHS THIRTY ONE
KNOWS SIX THIS SIMPLY MEANT.
I'M SORRY. THE MEASURE PASSES.
OUR MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FOLLOW ADAM ONE OLD FOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK. COPYRIGHT
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT I
DON'T. YES MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE
RE. ASSEMBLY BELL THIRTEEN OH
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN
ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS.
AMERICA YOUR MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN OH TWO ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK THIS BILL
CODIFIES REGULATIONS AT THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
ADOPTED WITH RESPECT TO
CANNABIS ADVERTISEMENT ALONG
HIGHWAYS SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW CANNABIS LICENSEES
TO ADVERTISE OR MARKET ON A
BILLBOARD ALONG A HIGHWAY AS
LONG AS THE BILLBOARD IS
FURTHER THAN FIFTY A FIFTEEN
MILE RADIUS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BORDER. LANGUAGE IN PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR STATES THAT A
LICENSEE SHALL NOT ADVERTISE OR
MARKET ON A BILLBOARD OR
SIMILAR ADVERTISING DEVICE
LOCATED ON INTERSTATE HIGHWAY
OR ON A STATE HIGHWAY WHICH
CROSSES THE CALIFORNIA BORDER
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
CONCLUDED THAT PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR QUOTE DOES NOT
CLARIFY TO WHAT EXTENT SUCH
PROHIBITIONS WOULD TAKE PLACE
AND FELT THAT A FIFTEEN MILE
RADIUS WAS APPROPRIATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BUREAU'S
REGULATIONS WERE CHALLENGED IN
THE SAN LUIS OBISPO COURT
WINNER TO SUMMARY JUDGMENT THAT
THE REGULATIONS CONFLICT WITH
STATE LAW THE SUPPORTERS AND
AUTHOR AND FRANKLY MYSELF
FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE THAT THE
ANALYSIS OF THE BOROUGH WAS
APPROPRIATE IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH PROP SIXTY FOUR AND IT'S
WHY THIS BILL WILL FORMALLY
CODIFIED THOSE REGULATIONS
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT CLOSING THE
DOOR ON THE ILLICIT MARKET.
WHICH IS WHERE MINERS GET
ACCESS TO CANNABIS WITH UNKNOWN
CONTAMINANTS AND THC LEVELS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE HELP THE
LEGAL MARKET TO GROW AND THRIVE
IN AN ORGANIZED AND REGULATED
MANNER HE B. TWELVE THIRTEEN OH
TWO STRIKES THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCE BETWEEN PROTECTING
MINORS WHICH IS REALLY THE
PURPOSE OF THIS PARTICULAR
SECTION AND PROVIDING CANNABIS
LICENSEES WITH THE LIMITED TOOL
TO ADVERTISE TO THEIR AUDIENCE
AND I RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS TODAY. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER THIS RATE ON THE
SIDE. HEARING CENA NAINA. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE I DON'T WANT FOR. ALAN.
ARCHULETA HI AT KENS FIVE
EIGHTHS NO BACKER. GORGEOUS NO
BRADFORD I COME BY IT- I
PROTESTED I DALLY. NO DODD. HI
TORONTO I EXAMINE I GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE I GROVE. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO NO
JONES NO KIM AUGER I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MON. MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH. I CAN
FOURTEEN TINA. ROTH HI RUBIO.
SCANNER I STERN AMBERG. WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WELL I. M.
CENTER PLEASE CALL UP SOME
NUMBERS. ALAN BACKER. GROVE NO
LIVE MON. NIELSEN NO. PAN
FORTINO. RUBIO STERN AMBERG.
THE US SENATOR MOVES TO CALL.
MEMBERS THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO FILE I DON'T WANT TO
CENTER ALAN ARE YOU PREPARED. I
I'VE CERTAINLY BILL BY SENATOR
ASSEMBLYMAN BRIAN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRIAN AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING. SOONER
ALAN MEMBER A- TEN FOR THREE
LATITUDE IN CAP TO STATE
HOUSING LAW COMPRISED OF
INDIVIDUALS LIVING BELOW. 30%
OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME. IN
LAW DEFINES FOUR INCOME
CATEGORIES OF THE LOWEST
CATEGORY COMPRISED OF
HOUSEHOLDS LIVING BEFORE BELOW
THIRTY PERCENT. WE'RE MOVING IT
DOWN TO FIFTEEN SO THIS IS AN
I. Q. B. LOW INCOME CATEGORY.
AT THE END THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF HOW
MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE ON
THE BRINK. OF POTENTIALLY
BECOMING ON HOUSEPLANTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE SIGN ON. HEARING T. NINE
MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF. HEARING CENA AND AJ THIRTY
NINE KNOWS WITH ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. SOME MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM ONE
FIVE TWO. FOLLOW THE ON. ONE
FIVE TWO. BY SENATOR TOM AUGER.
M. SECTOR PLEASE RE ASSEMBLY
BILL AT THREE THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR CAN LONGER AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL GANGS
SOONER COME OVER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
THREE THREE THREE THE STEP
FORWARD ACT WHICH SEEKS TO
BRING DUE PROCESS TO OUR GANG
ENHANCEMENT STATUTE THISBILL
IS ALSO A CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
ON THE REVISION OF THE PENAL
CODE POLICY. RECOMMENDATION
CURRENTLY GANG ENHANCEMENTS ARE
OFTEN USED AS PROPORTIONATELY
AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
HAVE RESULTED IN A SYSTEMIC
CRIMINALIZATION. OF CULTURES
AND COMMUNITIES OUR GANG
ENHANCEMENTS STATUTES HAVE
VAGUE DEFINITIONS WEAK
STANDARDS OF PROOF AND ARE
PERHAPS THE MOST RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY PARTOF OUR
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. 92% OF
PEOPLE WITH GANG ENHANCEMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA OR PEOPLE OF
COLOR. EIGHTY THREE THREE THREE
MAKES CHANGES TO THE LAW THAT
WILL REDUCE PROSECUTORIAL OVER
REACH IN CRIMINAL CASES. IT
ALSO MAKES THE STANDARDS FOR
pMORE TRANSPARENT RE ENGINEERING
GANG ENHANCEMENTS TO FUNCTION
AS ORIGINALLY INTENDED. THIS
BILL DOES NOT SEEK TO MAKE THE
APPLICATION OF A GANG
ENHANCEMENT IMPOSSIBLE IT DOES
NOT TAKE AWAY THE APPLICATION
OF A GANG ENHANCEMENT. RATHER
IT REQUIRES THAT SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE BE PROVIDED IN ORDER
TO PROVE THAT THE UNDERLYING
OFFENSE WAS ACTUALLY COMMITTED
ON BEHALF OF THE GAME. THE
SENSIBLE CHANGE WILL ENSURE
THAT GANG ENHANCEMENTS ARE
APPLIED. TO THE MOST SERIOUS
AND VIOLENT OFFENSES AND ACT IF
YOU CHARGE A GANG ENHANCEMENT
YOU CAN PROVE. THAT ENHANCEMENT
IS TRUE. BY ADDRESSING SEVERAL
DAMAGING EFFECTS OF GANG
EVIDENCE AT TRIAL IN NARROWING
THE APPLICABILITY OF SUCH
EVIDENCE AB THREE THREE THREE
TAKES AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD
AT UNDOING SOME OF THE HARM
CAUSED BY CURRENT CURRENT GANG
ENHANCEMENT. STATUTES THIS BILL.
WHAT HAVING A GHOST. WE HAVE TO
A NUMBER OF. AMENDMENTS THROUGH
EVERY PORTION OF THIS PROCESS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR NELSON. BUT FIRST
LATER ON THE SENATE FIVE URGE A
NO VOTE. THE GANG AND GANG
ACTIVITY IS A GANG AND GANG
ACTIVITY OTHER RAPPERS. IN
AMERICA TODAY AND IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY AND THEY HAVE BEEN INDEED
FOR DECADES. AND CROSSING OUR
BORDERS ARE NOW OR DOZENS MORE
COMING IN FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
GANGS. THE PREDATORS WHO DID WE
GIVE THE DEPREDATIONS UPON OUR
CITIZENS. FROM LOS ANGELES TO
THE TINY LITTLE SO AND COUNTY
WE HAVE ACTIVE GAME GO. UNDER
VIOLENT WHATEVER THE ETHNICITY
OF THE GANG MEMBERS AREN'T
THERE ALL KINDS OF GAMES AND I
HAVE SEEN AN INTERVIEW TOMORROW.
WHAT THEY ARE COMMITTING UPON
OUR POPULATION. DEGREE JUST IN
REVERSE. FOR EXAMPLE THE ENTRY
PATHWAY. IT INTO GANGS IS TO
ASSAULT OR KILL. SO THAT'S NO
BIG DEAL NO HEAVENS NO NO NO WE
DON'T WANNA POUR LITTLE GANG
MEMBERS. WE WANT TO
REHABILITATE WELL INDEED I HAVE
WORKED IN MY HEART FOR THE
BABIES THE CHILD THESE GANG
MEMBERS WORK. AND I'VE ACTUALLY
SAID THE PARENTS. WHO CAME AND
SAID THAT MY GANG MEMBER COME
HOME. IF I COULD PUT YOU IN AND
LET THEM OUT. BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN RAISED IN THE ROOM SOME OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS. BY THEIR
PARENTS. THE GANG MEMBERS. THIS
CREATES A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
PATHWAY. YOU ASKED ME OTHER
THAN A HANDFUL OF STORES THE
ASIAN CALIFORNIA. IF THEY THINK
THAT THIS IS GOING TO HELP
ALLEVIATE OR PROVOKE JUSTICE
THE GANG MEMBERS WHO COMMIT
THESE HEINOUS GANG. CRIMES I
THINK NOT. IT BREAKS IT MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT END ALLOWING THE
FRENCH TO DEMAND. A SEPARATE
TRIAL. ONCE SHEPHERD OF
ACTIVITIES THE GANG MEMBERS
ENGAGING. THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THAT IS JUST TO MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO EXTRAORDINARILY
DIFFICULT TO PROSECUTE GANG
MEMBERS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THINK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT THINK
ABOUT YOUR OWN NEIGHBORHOODS.
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU READ IN
THE PAPER AND YOU SEE ON THE
NEWS. AND SAY THAT THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE. BUT THAT'S
OKAY. NO IT IS NOT OKAY. AND
THIS IS NOT A PATHWAY TO
JUSTICE IT IS THE DESTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE. TO THE PRIVATE
CITIZENS TWO LAW AND ORDER AND
TO JUSTICE FOR THOSE. WHO HARM
THEIR FELLOW CALIFORNIANS I
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THE SIDE I'M SENATOR BOARDS
WHICH. MR PRESIDENT I RISE-
ECHOING SOME OF THE THOUGHTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE JUST MENTIONED.
THE LINE THAT USED TO EXIST
MAYBE AT ONE POINT IN TIME
BETWEEN ST. FIVE ACTIVITY IN
WHITE COLLAR ACTIVITIES
DEFINITELY BEEN BLURRED. STREET
GANGS HAVE CERTAINLY BECOME
MORE SOPHISTICATED OVER TIME.
THEN WE USE THE EXAMPLE OF MAIL
THEFT OR IDENTITY THEFT STREET
GANGS ARE PART OF A PROFIT
RACKETEERING ENTERPRISE. AND SO
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SET SEPARATE.
SOME OF THESE OFFENSES FROM THE
ENHANCEMENT PROCESS YOU ARE
ALLOWING THE FUNDING
CAPABILITIES OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE. SO
WHETHER THEY'RE SELLING
NARCOTICS OR ENGAGING IN OTHER
TYPES OF CRIMINAL MISCONDUCT
THE PROFIT COMPONENT OF A GANG
IS THE BEATING HEART OF AGAIN.
AND SO TO TAKE THAT AWAY FROM
ENHANCEMENT IS TO DO AWAY WITH.
UNDOING RACKETEERING IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND SO I DON'T I DON'T
SEE IT AS CONSISTENT THAT IF
YOU WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
YOU DEPRIVE THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT OF THE LIFE BLOOD WHICH
IS THE FINANCIAL COMPONENT THAT
YOU CAN ALLOW THIS TO OCCUR.
ADD ON TOP ON TOP OF THIS THE
OWNERS COMPONENT OF HAVING
PROSECUTION. WAITRESS SEPARATE-
PROVE UP- PROCEDURE TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO EVEN USE THE
ENHANCEMENTS TO ME THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY INCOMPATIBLE. IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE AWAY THE FUNDING
SOURCE OF GANG ACTIVITY YOU
CANNOT ALLOW THE SECOND
SEGREGATION OF THESE PARTICULAR
OFFENSES. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. AND SEEN ON INTERCOM
ORDER GEORGE CLOSE. YES THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT YOU KNOW IT'S
SOME ALWAYS DIFFICULT TO TALK
ABOUT A BILL. THAT DEALS WITH
GANGS BECAUSE IMMEDIATELY WE
LEAN INTO MOVIES THAT WE HAVE
SEEN LIKE COLORS MENACE TO
SOCIETY WE LEAN ON OUR OWN
STEREO TYPES AND FEARS. AND
BIASES AND MANY OF THOSE ARE
LEGITIMATE THIS BILL DOES NOT
CONDONE. ACTIONS OF GANGS OR
GANG MEMBERS I DON'T LIKE GANGS
I DON'T LIKE THEM IN MY
COMMUNITY. I CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT THEM HURTING PEOPLE THAT I
KNOW OR EVEN PEOPLE THAT I
DON'T KNOW THIS ISN'T ABOUT
THAT. THIS IS ABOUT DUE PROCESS
AND THE FACT THAT WHOEVER YOU
ARE WHEREVER YOU LIVE WHATEVER
YOU LOOK LIKE IF YOU HAVE A
LONG HAIR OR A SHAVED HEAD IF
YOU HAVE TATTOOS OR NOT. IF YOU
HAVE COMMITTED A CRIME OR NOT
IF YOU ARE IN A GAME OR NOT. IF
YOU ARE. WELL I WON'T EVEN GO
THERE BUT REGARDLESS OF WHO YOU
ARE IF YOU ARE CHARGED WITH A
CRIME. AND YOU DON'T PLAY OUT.
THE PROSECUTION HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO PROVE THAT YOU
COMMITTED THE CRIME. IF ANY OF
YOU. I'VE HAD ALLEGATIONS
LEVIED AGAINST YOU WHETHER THEY
HAVE BEEN TRUE OR NOT YOU WOULD
WANT THOSE CHARGES COULD BE
PROVEN YOU WOULD NOT WANT FOLKS
TO LEAN INTO A BIAS OR A STEREO
TYPE OR A FEAR OF YOU. AND LET
THAT BECOME A YES OR NO
QUESTION RATHER THAN TO PROVE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT. I
AGREE MANY GANGS. HAVE A PROFIT
MOTIVE. MANY GANGS ARE SAVVY
AND SOPHISTICATED AND HIGHLY
ORGANIZED WHICH IS WHY I
QUESTIONED THE OPPOSITION'S
PUSH TO SAY THAT GANGS ARE NOT
ORGANIZED THAT THEY ARE I'M
ORGANIZED AND FLUID. BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT. I WISH THIS BILL
WASN'T AS STRINGENT AS THE
RECALL LAWS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
BOOKS. HEY MAN I YES YES I DO
BUT THEY'RE NOT THIS IS NOT
UNFORTUNATELY. THE REALITY IS.
A YOUNG MAN NAMED RAYMOND. WHO
HAPPENED TO BE IN A GANG. STOLE
SOME BEER AND A GALLON OF MILK.
HE DID NOT STEAL BACK BECAUSE
HE WAS IN A GANG HE STOLE IT
BECAUSE HE WAS DESPERATE AND
MAKING A BAD DECISION. A GANG
ALLEGATION WAS LEVIED AGAINST
HIM. BECAUSE HE HAPPENED TO
HAVE BEEN IN A GAME THE CRIME
WAS NOT BASED ON HIS
AFFILIATION. DEFENSE HAD TO
pCOMPARE THAT WITH TERRELL A
YOUNG MAN. WHO WAS A CRYPT. WHO
MURDERED A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
POSTED IT ON HIS SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE'RE GETTING SIGNS AND LOGOS.
WHEN WAS APPOINTED WITHOUT A
GANG ALLEGATIONS BEING LEVIED
ON HIM HE WAS YES A YOUNG WHITE
HIGH SCHOOL OR FROM PALACE
THIRTIES. SO WE HAVE THAT STRY
WASN'T TRUE IF THOSE TWO
STORIES WEREN'T TRUE I WOULDN'T
BE HERE. THE FACT THAT JAMES
AND MIKE. WHO ARE ARIAN
BROTHERHOOD GANG MEMBERS
ACTIVELY INVOLVED. IN MURDEROUS
ACTIVITIES AND SELLING MATH WHO
HAVE REPEATEDLY GONE TO PRISON.
WHAT EIGHT EIGHT TATTOOED ON
THEIR FOREHEAD FOR HEIL HITLER.
AND HAVE NEVER HAD A GANG
ALLEGATION LEVIED AGAINST THEM.
IF I HAVEN'T HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION WHO TOLD ME
THAT QUITE FRANKLY MISSED
CAMELOT OCCUR BLACK AND BROWN
GANGS ARE JUST FAR MORE
DANGEROUS THAN ANY OTHER GANGS.
THEN I WOULDN'T BE HERE I'M NOT
MAKING UP THESE STORIES.
ULTIMATELY WHAT I'M SAYING IS
THAT IF YOU WANT TO CHARGE
SOMEONE PUT THE CASE. BECAUSE
GOING TO JAIL FOR A LIFETIME
BECAUSE SOMEONE LOOKS AT YOU
AND SAYS YOU HAVE A SHAVED HEAD
BECAUSE SOME POLICE OFFICER
IDENTIFIED YOU BASED ON MAYBE
THEIR OWN BIASES OR WHAT THEY
HAVE SEEN. SHOULD NOT ALLOW YOU
TO BE SENT TO PRISON BECAUSE OF
A GANG ALLEGATION WITH A TERM
THAT IS LONGER. THEN WHEN THE
BASE CRIME IS. I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU THAT 96% OF THESE CASES.
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU. THAT GANG
MEMBERS DON'T DO STUFF IN THE
DARK OF NIGHT AND THEN RUN AND
HIDE AND SAY WELL I'M NOT IN A
GAME. IF YOU'RE IN A GANG IN
YOUR ACTIVE. YOU'RE PROUD
THAT'S PART OF YOUR BRAND.
REGARDLESS OF IF IT'S GOOD TO
BE IN AGAIN I'M NOT DISPUTING
THAT. BUT FOLKS DON'T PRETEND
LIKE THEY'RE IN A GANG AND THEN
DON'T PRETEND LIKE THEY'RE IN A
GAME BECAUSE IF YOU'RE DOING IT
FOR THE BENEFIT OF ONE FOR YOUR
FINANCIAL GAME. FOR EXPANSION
OF TERRITORY DID YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT IN WHICH
CASE IT SHOULD BE PRETTY EASY
TO PROVE. IT SHOULD BE PRETTY
EASY TO PROVE. AB THREE THREE
THREE SAYS IF YOU TELL SOMEONE
THE CASE. WITH ONE TO PROCESS
IS ABOUT THAT'S WHAT A FAIR
TRIAL SHOULD BE ABOUT. THAT'S
WHAT THE COURT OF LAW. SO WE
SHOULD BE DOING. PEOPLE CREATE
WILL DO BAD THINGS GANG MEMBERS
DO BAD THINGS. THEY DO ENGAGE
IN CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. AND IF
THEY ARE CAUGHT THEY SHOULD BE
CHARGED. YOU CAN PROVE IT YOU
HAVE EVIDENCE SO FAR. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL SAYS THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL WILL STILL ALLOW. AND
FOR ANYONE TO TELL YOU THAT
THIS IS A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE
CARD. EITHER DOESN'T KNOW THE
LAW. OR IS TRYING TO SCARE YOU.
AND THE UNFORTUNATE THING IS IT
IS SO INCREDIBLY EASY TO SCARE
YOU WHEN YOU SAY THE WORD GANG.
I COME FROM A COMMUNITY WHERE A
FAMILY MEMBER. WAS SHOT DEAD IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE STREET AND
LEFT TO DIE IN HIS LIVING ROOM
BLOOD OUT FOR TEN HOURS. GANG
INVOLVEMENT. I WOULD NOT WANT
TO PASS A BILL THAT WOULD SAVE
HIS LIFE IS FORGOTTEN. BUT EVEN
THAT PERSON WHO DID THAT.
DESERVES A FAIR TRIAL. THAT'S
WHAT THE COURT IS ABOUT THAT'S
WHAT THE LAW IS ABOUT. LAWYERS
GO INTO BATTLE WITH THE
EVIDENCE TO PROVE THEIR CASE.
AND IF YOU ARE GOOD AND
STRATEGIC YOU WILL WIN. IN LOS
ANGELES WE HAVE EIGHT LARGE
GANG PROBLEM. NDAS ARE TELLING
ME EVERY DAY WE ARE BEING AS
CREATIVE AS POSSIBLE. USING ALL
KINDS OF OOLS IN OUR DISPOSAL
THANK YOU LEGISLATURE TO GET
FOLKS. AND THEY ARE. BUT YOU
SHOULDN'T BE PUTTING SOMEONE
AWAY FOR FIFTEEN YEARS BECAUSE
THEY STOLE A GALLON OF MILK FOR
THEIR BABY WHO IS HUNGRY. AND
SIX YEARS AGO THEY HAPPEN TO BE
IN A GANG. BECAUSE HERE IF
YOU'RE IN ONE. YOU HAVE TO
REGISTER AND ONLY FOREVER.
REGARDLESS OF IF YOU AGED OUT
OF A GAME. MANY OF US HAVE AGED
OUT OF THINGS HAVE YOU AGED OUT
OF A MARRIAGE AND SOMEONE COMES
BACK TO YOU AND STILL HARKENS
TO THAT TIME. THAT'S A LITTLE
UNFAIR. IT'S AN INNOCUOUS
EXAMPLE. BUT IT PROVES A POINT.
EIGHTY THREE THREE THREE IS
ABOUT DUE PROCESS. DO YOU THINK
THAT IF YOU CHARGE SOMEONE WITH
A CRIME YOU SHOULD PROVE THAT
THEY DID IT. THAT IS WHAT AB
THREE THREE THREE TO US I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU AND MA'AM SECTOR
LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON. FILE
ITEM. ONE FIVE TWO. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. ADKINS FIVE BASE NO
BACKER HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD I
COME BY OTHER. CORTEZ THREE I
DALLY NO DOG HI TORONTO HI
AIKMAN FIVE GLAZER. GONZALES I
GROVE NO HERTZBERG FIVE WEST SO
HI HER TADO NO JONES NO
KAMMERER I LAYERED. I LLEVA I
THE MON I WIRE I MELINDA'S NO
MEN I NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO OCHO
ALTHOUGH NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO
HI RALPH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL NO PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
COME BY OTHER. LASER. GLAZER I
NEWMAN. STERN AMBERG. ALL EYES
THIRTY TWENTY FIVE NOS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. NON MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT ONE SEVENTY
TWO. ONE SEVENTY TWO CENTER
WINNER FOR A CINNAMON LOW. M.
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACT
RELATING TO CIVIL RIGHTS.
SENIOR WINNER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT CALLING SIDE AB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR- WILL RECALL
REQUIRES A RETAILER WITH FIVE
HUNDRED OR MORE EMPLOYEES- TO
PROVIDE A GENDER NEUTRAL RETAIL
SECTION FOR CHILDREN'S ITEMS
ARE TOYS AND CHILDCARE ITEMS.
ON IF THE RETAILER CHOOSES TO
MAINTAIN THE LABELING OF KID
SECTIONS FOR BOYS AND GIRLS IF
THE RETAILER CHOOSES TO SIMPLY.
LABEL SECTIONS TOYS OUR KIDS
AND NON URGENT AND NON GENDERED
WAYS- THE ADDITIONAL GENDER
NEUTRAL SECTION WILL NOT BE
NECESSARY IN OTHER WORDS IF THE
RETAILERS WILL ONLY HAVE TO
PROVIDE A GENDER NEUTRAL
SECTION IF THEY MAINTAIN
SECTIONS FOR BOYS AND GIRLS. HI
THIS IS SIMILAR TO WHEN THE
STATE DECIDED TO ADD GENDER
NEUTRAL BATHROOMS- WERE
NECESSARY TO ADOPT WHAT SOCIETY
NEEDS TO BE FUNCTIONAL-
INCLUSIVE. IN TODAY'S CULTURE
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE STOP
REINFORCING GENDER NORMS THAT
CAN BE HARMFUL TO CHILDREN.
THIS LEGISLATION DOES NOT APPLY
TO SMALL BUSINESSES. ON AS A
COVER NINETY RESTRICTIONS-
HOPEFULLY LESSEN AT SOME POINT
IN THE NEAR FUTURE- AND KIDS
START GOING BACK TO SCHOOL AS
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING IN RECENT
WEEKS AND WE'LL SEE MORE AND
MORE ACTIVITY- WE WANT THE
PROCESS OF SHOPPING TO BE A
POSITIVE EXPERIENCE. AFTER THIS
UNPRECEDENTED YEAR OF STRESS-
WERE WANNA CREATE A WELCOMING
PLACE FOR ALL CHILDREN- MOVING
AWAY FROM STEREOTYPES LIKE BLUE
IS FOR BOYS AND PINK IS FOR
GIRLS- THE DAUGHTER OF. A
DAUGHTER OF THE ALTAR STAFF WAS
WALKING THROUGH THE PARK AND
STORE RECENTLY- AND SAID MOM I
KNOW YOU WILL LET ME SHOP AND
THE BOYS DEPARTMENT BECAUSE I
LIKE GREENS AND BLUE BETTER
THAN SPARKLES HOWEVER I'VE
ASKED KIDS IN MY CLASS AND THEY
ALL WANT. TO AS WELL BUT SOME
OF THEIR PARENTS SAY NO BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THE SECTION IS
LABELED FOR BOYS AND GIRLS AND
QUOTE. THIS IS ABOUT MAKING
SPACE CITY SPACES FOR ALL
CHILDREN IN TODAY'S. SOCIETY
AND NOT PUSHING- AS AN FORCE
SOLD SECOND. TO GENDER. WHEN A
CHILD GOES INTO A LARGER STORE
WITH A CARETAKER OUR HOPE IS
THAT THE DOOR WILL BE BIASED BY
THE LABEL BORN GIRLS AND BOYS
SECTIONS- AND ONCE SETTLED ON A
CHILD- TO CHOOSE WHAT THE CHILD
WANTS. AND IF A BOY WANTS A
SHIRT THAT'S IN THE GIRLS
APARTMENT OR VICE VERSA.
THERE'S OFTEN A STIGMA
ASSOCIATED THAT MAKES THE CHILD
FEEL JUDGED WERE UNABLE TO
EXPRESS OUR DESIRE TO CHOOSE AN
ITEM FROM THE PRE LABELED
OPPOSITE. GENDER DEPARTMENT.
SEPARATING SIMILAR ITEMS THAT
ARE TRADITIONALLY MARKETED
EITHER FOR GIRLS OR FOR BOYS.
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE
CONSUMER TO COMPARE PRODUCTS.
INCORRECTLY IMPLIES THAT
THEY'RE USED BY ONE GENDER IS
INAPPROPRIATE- TARGET MADE
HEADLINES IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
WHEN IT DECIDED TO DO AWAY WITH
GENDER BASED SIGNS. IN SOME
DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS HOME AND
TOYS IN OTHER WORDS THIS IS
NOT. A NEW THING- WE ARE
ALREADY SEEING SOME OF THIS
HAPPENING IN THE SKY DID NOT.
FALL I'M SIMPLY PUT. HOW ABOUT
WE LET KIDS BE KIDS I'M NOT
GONNA BE WHO THEY ARE. I
RESPECT FILES FOR AN IPO. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. MELINDA'S SENATOR
MELINDA BUSH FOR GEORGE THANK
YOU- I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AND I WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT WE LET PARENTS BE PARENTS
AND MAKE THE DECISIONS THAT
THEY WANT TO MAKE FOR THEIR
KIDS ALONG WITH THEIR CHILDREN-
UNLIKE THE AUTHOR I ACTUALLY
HAVE CHILDREN FIVE OF THEM TO
BE EXACT I CAN TELL YOU THAT IT
IS. VERY CONVENIENT FOR PARENTS
WHEN THEY'RE SHOPPING TO KNOW
WHERE THE CLOTHING IS FOR THEIR
CHILD WHETHER IT'S A BOY OR
GIRL AN APPARENT ALREADY KNOWS
WHAT THEIR CHILD'S PREFERENCES
IT DOESN'T MATTER. WHERE IN THE
STORE PUTS IT OR THAT THEY MAKE
IT GENDER NEUTRAL THE PARENT
ALREADY KNOWS THIS MY GOODNESS
PARKING IS- PARENTS DON'T KNOW
THEIR OWN CHILDREN. AND AS
STATED BY THE FLOOR JOCKEY FROM
ONE RETAILER DECIDED TO DO THIS
ON THEIR OWN. OKAY WELL GREAT
WELL HOW ABOUT WE LET
BUSINESSES MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS BASED ON THE INPUT.
THEY GET FROM THEIR CUSTOMERS
BUT I DON'T THINK. THAT PARENTS
NEED THE GOVERNMENT TO STEP IN
AND TELL THEM. HOW THEY SHOULD
SHOP FOR THEIR CHILDREN. THIS
IS NONSENSE ORIGINAL ABOUT. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
CENTER FOR INTERNAL. YEAH I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF- AV CHANNEL
FOUR AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE A
PERSONAL STORY- THAT MY OWN
FAMILY EXPERIENCE TO WHERE MY
BROTHER WAS TAKING HIS DAUGHTER
TO ONE OF THE DRIVE INS AND ONE
OF THE FAST FOOD SHOPS FOR THE
FOR ONE OF THE CHILDREN'S
MEALS. AND THE PERSON ON THE
OTHER THE MICROPHONE SAID YOU
WANT A BOY TOY YEAR GIRL TOY.
AND MY BROTHER JUMPED OUT OF
HIS SEAT BECAUSE THERE'S NO
SUCH THING AS A BOY OR A GIRL
TIGER TOYS WE SHOULD NOT BE
USING GENDER SPECIFIC
DEFINITIONS WE SHOULD NOT BE WE
SHOULD BE SENSITIVE TO EVERYONE
AND SO THAT'S A REAL STORY THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS IMPORTANT
TO DO AND SEND A MESSAGE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING ON
HIDDEN WINNER WHICH OUGHT TO
CLOSE. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT I'M IT IS TRUE THAT-
THAT THE AUTHOR OF THE
LEGISLATION MR LOW- AS FAR AS I
KNOW A DOESN'T HAVE KIDS- EYES
A FOREMAN'S I ALSO DON'T HAVE
KIDS AND SOMETIMES THERE IS AN
ARGUMENT THAT'S MADE WELL
YOU'RE A CHILDLESS DEMAND SO
HOW DARE YOU HAVE OPINIONS.
ABOUT OUR CHILDREN OUR
FAMILIES- BUT I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT I DO KNOW FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND WHAT I KNOW THAT
MY CALLING THE AUTHOR IN HIS
FAMILY MR LOWE ALSO KNOWS- IS
WE KNOW WHY IT WAS LIKE. TO
GROW UP NOT CONFORMING TO THE
WAY THAT YOUR GENDER. IS
SUPPOSED TO BE. BUT THIS IS HOW
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE AS A
CHILD. AND EVEN WHEN YOU LIKE
MYSELF HAD WONDERFUL AFFIRMING
PARENTS SOCIETY YOUR CLASSMATES
OR TEACHERS EVERYONE ELSE'S
KANSEI TELLING YOU THIS IS THE
WAY IF YOU'RE A BOY THIS IS HOW
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE. OR IF
YOU'RE A GIRL THIS IS HOW
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE AND
THERE'S NO GRAY THERE'S NO
FLEXIBILITY YOU HAD BETTER DO
THIS AND SO I KNOW THAT AND I
KNOW THAT MISTER AND MISTER
LOWE KNOWS THAT FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT WHEN WE LOOK IN
THIS COUNTRY. ABOUT CHILDREN.
WHO ARE STIGMATIZED BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT CONFORMING TO WHAT
SOCIETY IS DEMANDING THAT THEY
BE. WHEN WE LOOK AT THE SUICIDE
RATE. AMONG LGBTQ CHILDREN.
PARTICULARLY TRANS CHILDREN.
BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING TOLD
CONSTANTLY THAT YOU MUST
CONFORM TO SOMETHING THAT YOU
ARE NOT. WE KNOW WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE CHILDREN WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED THAT HARM GROWING
UP AS A CHILD. AND SO WE KNOW
AND WE UNDERSTAND AND WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED IT FIRST HAND AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AIBO.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE I DON'T
WANT SOMEONE TO. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE NO
BACKER. HI FOR JUST NO BRADFORD
I COME BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI
DALLY NO DODD HI TORONTO. I
EGGMAN I BELIEVE- I CONSOLIDATE
HIGH GROWTH NO HERTZBERG HI
WEST SO. HER TADO. JONES NO
CAME UNDER. I LAYERED FIVE
LLEVA I THE MON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MEN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO CONTROL BOTH NO PAN
HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE STERN-
BERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER FIVE WELK NOPE. PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. WEST SO
I HER TADO I MIN STERN. HIGHS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO FALL ITEM. ONE
SEVEN EIGHT. FOLLOWING ONE FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT YES BUT WHO.
SENATOR WIENER. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE FOLLOW ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN AN ACT RELATING TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
THROUGH WINTER FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
TO PRESENT A B. TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN- THIS LEGISLATION
CLARIFIES THAT THE CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK THE I. BANK.
MAY FINANCE HOUSING AS PART OF
AN OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE PROJECTS-
WHEN THE ELEMENT OF HOUSING IS
REQUIRED FOR THE OPERATION
ABOUT OVERALL POLITICAL
PROJECT. THE BILL ALSO MAKES
CLEAR THAT THE HOUSING PROJECT
CANNOT BE FINANCED WITH TAX
EXEMPT BONDS TO ENSURE THERE'S
NO CONFLICT WITH OTHER STATE
HOUSING FINANCING PROGRAMS
UNDER CURRENT LAW I BANK IS
AUTHORISED TO FINANCE A WIDE
VARIETY OF PUBLIC AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS BUT ITEXPRESSLY AND CATEGORICALLY
EXCLUDES HOUSING- WITHOUT
DEFINING THE SCOPE WITHOUT
RESTRICTION OR A CLEAR
INDICATION OF WHY. THIS
ABSOLUTE PROHIBITION ON HOUSING
AND I BANK ACT CREATIVE
FINANCING JOBS- THAT EXCLUDES
ALL PROJECTS EVEN IF IT
CONTAINS A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
HOUSING- THIS RESULTS IN HIGHER
FINANCING COSTS OR CAN EVEN
HOLD A PROJECT ENTIRELY HE
TAUGHT NINETY FIVE SIMPLY
ALLOWS THESE PROJECTS TO BE
ELIGIBLE BY DEFINING THE SCOPE
OF THE HOUSING- RESTRICTING IN
THE HOUSING RESTRICTION AND I
BANKED ACTED MORE CLEARLY. IT'S
A STRAIGHTFORWARD BELTS
RECEIVED VOTE. OF
SUPPORT AND I ASK FOR I'M A-
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THIS ON ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS RAID ON THE
SIDE OF HEARING SEEN ON MOUNT
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON
FOLLOWING HIM ONE SEVEN EIGHT.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. HI AT KINS.
EIGHT I BACKER. HI FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD. I COME BY ADAM I
PROTESTING FIVE DALLY. I DONT I
THERE ARE SO I EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROVE.
HI HURTS BERG I WAS SO. I HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA. I LIVE ALONE
HI MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM I PERSON TINA I
BROUGHT. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG I Y. CASKEY I
WINNER HI WELL HI. PLEASE CALL
UP TO MEMBERS. ATKINS I
MELINDA'S STERN. THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NON
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX. SENATOR
ALAN FOR FEATURING NORGE YOU
PREPARED IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRI
NORRIS AN ACT RELATING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
DECLARING THEIR INSTANT URGENCY
THERE OF STEAK FRITES MEDIALLY.
ENTER OUR- MEMBERS WILL
REMEMBER THE DEBACLE AT ET DE.
AND THE FACT THAT WE HAD FOLKS
WHO WERE ENGAGING AND- ILLICIT
ACTIVITY FRAUD ASSOCIATED WITH
YOU WITH UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
FOLKS IN IN THE PRISONS AND
SOMEHOW RESEARCH ABOUT NEARLY A
BILLION DOLLARS- BECAUSE THE
PRISONS DIDN'T HAVE A SYSTEM TO
REGULATE CROSS MATCH YOU I
CLAIMS WITH INFORMATION FROM
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY SO THIS
IS THIS BILL GOES DIRECTLY AT
THAT PROBLEM. IT REQUIRES THE
EMPLOYMENT OF ALL THE
DEPARTMENT E. D. TO CROSSCHECK
INCARCERATION RECORDS WITH THE
pCALIFORNIA PART OF ORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION OR TO
PREVENT PAIN FRAGILE BENEFITS-
IT IS IT'S A IT'S A SIMPLE
COMMON SENSE STEPS TO PREVENT
FRAUD IDENTITY THEFT IT WAS A-
MAJOR EMBARRASSMENT FOR ALL OF
US. IN THIS BILL- SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
GREAT ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR CAMARGO. PRESIDENT I
WILL BE VOTING ON THIS BILL AB
ONE TEN AND URGE OTHERS TO DO
THE SAME I ALSO DO JUST WANT TO
SAY FOR THE RECORD THAT THERE
WERE ALSO A NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO
ARE INCARCERATED WHO WERE
VICTIMS OF IDENTITY THEFT. AND
SO I WANT US TO ALSO INCLUDE
THAT IN THE NARRATIVE. OF
WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON BECAUSE
THERE ARE FOLKS WHO ARE FREE.
LIVING IN THEIR HOMES ACROSS
OUR DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE.
WHO ARE USING THE IDENTITIES OF
FOLKS WHO ARE INCARCERATED TO
STEAL MONEY THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN GOING TO TAX PAYING
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEEDED THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL ON A. B. WANTED.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE SIDE OF.
ENGINE ON CENTER ELEMENT TO
LOOK CLOSE I THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES SHE'S ACTUALLY
RIGHT AND IT IS SHE POINTS OUT
THE FACT THAT THEY WERE THERE
WERE MANY VICTIMS HERE- AND I
WANT TO. RESPECT US FOR ABOUT.
MMHM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS. I'M SORRY THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
RECALLS OR ANY OBJECTIONS TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THE SIDE OF. CURRENCY NINE
HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOT. NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FALL ITEM.
TWO THIRTY. WE HAVE A CERTAIN
REMEMBER RADIUS AND WE HAVE
SOONER BACKER HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWELVE BY
FAMILY MEMBER AS AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE GOVERNMENT. I
THINK THAT- FLOORS RICH THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT A BEFORE ONE
TWO WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON HUMAN
RIGHTS. THE COMMISSION WOULD BE
COMPRISED OF LEADERS. COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND LEGISLATORS WHICH
SERVICE ADVISORY BOARD
RESPONSIBLE FOR YOU IN THE
STATUS OF HUMAN RIGHTS ACROSS
OUR STATE. THE SUCCESSFUL
PASSAGE OF THE SENATE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
ESSENTIALLY SURE IT WAS AMENDED
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED. HONORING HUMAN RIGHTS
ARE CORNERSTONE OF OUR STATE.
AND OUR DEMOCRACY THE
TECHNICIAN WILL HELP ENSURE WE
CONTINUE MARCHING TOWARDS A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL WITHOUT A
SPECIAL ASTRONAUT VOTE. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
AND SEEING NAINA- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE I'M TWO THIRTY. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I AT KINS. BAYTEX
BACKER HI PORGES NO BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM ARE YOU PROTECTING.
I DALLY. DODD HI THERE I WASN'T
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI
WEST SO HI- TIDO HI JONES. NO
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I
LIVE MON HI WIRE. REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO- CHOKE. HI PAM I
FORTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG HI BY
KELSEY FIVE WINNER I WILL.
MANCHESTER POLICE CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS. ATKINS BAIT NO BALLY.
STERN WELL. NO. HIGHS THIRTY NO
SIX SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
DOWN MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEMS. TWO FORTY ONE. FOR
WE HAVE A SEVEN MEMBER COURT.
SENATE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
SHE'S PREPARED MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNICATIONS CENTER HERZBERG.
THANKS VERY MUCH THIS MEASURE
WILL ALIGN CALIFORNIA LAW WITH
THE CURRENT FEDERAL LAW
REGARDING THE APPROVAL PROCESS
OF WIRELESS TELECOMMUNICATION
APPLICATIONS AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL CLARITY THAT WILL
ALLOW APPLICANTS TO DEPLOY
COMMUNICATIONS TECHNOLOGY
QUICKLY. THE SURVEY INDICATED
42% OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
SEATED THE UNRELIABLE INTERNET
ACCESS HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR
THEM DURING FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES AS FOR NOVEL.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM FOLLOWING
TWO FOUR ONE. HERE IN C. NINE-
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF. SHE NINE OZ THIRTY NINE
KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NON MEMBERS WERE MOVING
TO FALL ITEM THREE OH THREE. BY
FAR CARRYING ON PRESENTED BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ SHE'S READY.
AND I'M SECRETARY YOU MARY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE
HAND AN ACT RELATING TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. SENATOR GONZALES
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I'M-
PROUD TO PRESENT B THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARRICADE HAD A BILL THAT
UPDATES OUR LAWS. TO ADDRESS
THE INSIDIOUS THREATS THAT
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS FACE
EVERY PRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CLINICS- IT ALSO UPDATES OUR
LAWS TO INCLUDE ONLINE THREATS
INCREASED FINES FOR
INTENTIONALLY TERRORIZING
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS. AND
ALSO INCLUDES NEEDED TRAINING
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BETTER
HANDLE THESE DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS. ARE THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE OF
EIGHT AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
GROWTH. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IF IT WASN'T FOR PROJECT
VERITAS AND ALL OF THOSE-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT VIDEOTAPED
MEMBERS OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
WE WOULD NOT KNOW THAT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD WAS SELLING BABY
BODY PARTS FOR PROFIT. SO I
RAISE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO THINK OF- YOU
KNOW PROTECTING ALL WOMEN
INCLUDING THOSE THAT ARE ON
BOARD. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF.
ENGINE NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
WANNA SAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL CALIFORNIANS OVER THIS
LAST YEAR HAVE BEEN HARASSED
I'M ENTERING PROTECTED HEALTH
CLINICS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE I'M THRILLED.
THRILLED THREE. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS BASE NO
BACKER I PORCHES. NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A ARE YOU PROTESTING HI
DOLLY. NO DODD FIVE TORONTO I
HAD BEEN. I GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE ARI GROVE NO
HERTZBERG HI WEST SO I HER TADO
I JONES NO CAMCORDER I LAYERED
I. LEIVA. I THE MON I WIRE. HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A CHOKE NO PAN HI
FORTUNE. FIVE ROTH. I RUBIO HI
SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER FIVE
WACO SKI NO WINNER. I WILL LOOK
NO PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS ATKINS STERN EYES
TWENTY EIGHT NEWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING TOO FAR BACK TO FILE
ITEM. TO SIXTEEN. WHICH IS
SENATOR BRADFORD. THE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE AN ACT RELATING TO
CORRECTIONS CENTER REFERRED.
YEAH BABY TWO NINE TWO WE'LL
JUST GIVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED A CHANCE TO
PRIORITIZE YOUR REHABILITATION
BY GIVING THEM THE TOOLS TO
WORK TOWARD SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
INTO THEIR COMMUNITIES. THIS
COMMON SENSE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
A CDC ARE TO IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS
THAT BALANCE IN PERSON AN
ALTERNATIVE PROGRAMMING SENATE
AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE CREDITS
PORTIONS OF THE BILL AND
STRICTLY FOCUSES ON THE BILLS.
ON THE BILL ON INCREASING
ACCESS TO PROGRAM PROGRAMMING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM.
M. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS BATES. BACKER FIVE PORGES.
BRADFORD. I HAVE A. CORE CORE
TESTING HI DOLLY NO DOG. HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN I LASER I
CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROVE NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
NO JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S.NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A TURBO. I
PAN I FORTUNE TINO HI ROSS I
RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE STERNE
AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NOW M. THIRTY
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBERS
ATKINS. BAYTEX PORGES. BY ADAM
I. STERN. HIGHS THIRTY NO SIX
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WERE GONNA NEED DRAWING THE
FLOOR GONNA BE LIFTING CALLS
SHORTLY.
MEMBERS SCHLEMMER
GONNA LOOK TO CALL CALL ON
SEVERAL ITEMS AND HOPEFULLY
WE'RE ALREADY WORKING FOR START
WOULD. FALL ITEMS SIXTY NINE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THAT SOME MEMBERS. WEST SO. I
LLEVA HI RUBIO I STERN. FIVE
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON THE FALL ITEM SEVENTY.
MMHM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THAT
SOME MEMBERS. EIGHT PORGES.
DALLY NO. GROVE WEST SO. I
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. NIELSEN
RUBIO I STERN. PRICE THIRTY
THREE KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON THE FALL
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR. PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS. DALLY ARGUMENT
I WEST SO. I MELINDA'S I. RUBIO
I STERN. TALLY HI. FIVE THIRTY
NINE KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NON MEMBERS MOVE IN THE
FALL I DON'T NINETY TWO. TALLY
I. EGGMAN I RUBIO HI STERN
NIELSEN. THIS CALLED ABBAS A
MEMBER DRUMMER JOHN NIELSEN.
STERN. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON THE FALL OF NINETY
SEVEN. ALAN I DALLY I. GONZALEZ.
CAN LONGER. RUBIO I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY SIX KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON
TO FALL I DON'T. NINETY EIGHT.
BASED NO FOR JUST NARROW DALLY.
GROSS. THE TROUBLE. I TRIED
BOTH. A TROUBLED I. RUBIO I
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY ONE NOTES
SECTION THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE LINE ONE
HUNDRED. ARCHULETA I DALLY NO
GROVE. I RUBIO I STERN.
MELINDA'S NOTIFY. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT MILLS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO FALL
ITEM. ONE TWENTY FIVE. RUBIO. I
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS
IT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
FOLLOWING ITEM. ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. EIGHT FOR JUST. GROVE
WEST SO. I MELINDA'S. NIELSEN
NO. RUBIO I STERN. MELINDA'S I.
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBERS. BASE
FOR JUST. GROVE STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ONE ON THE
URGENCY MARCH THIRTY FIVE KNOWS
ONE ON THE MEASURE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM. ONE TWENTY NINE. THE
TALLY. I BRIVIO I STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NO MEMBERSHIP
MOVING ON THE FALL ITEM ONE
THREE ONE. LIMO ON. RUBIO I
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING. TO ONE THREE TWO. CAM
WALKER. THE MON. RUBIO I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN MILLS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW TO FILE
I DON'T ONE THREE SIX. FOUR I'M
SORRY ONE THREE FOUR. LET ALONE.
FOURTEEN TINA. RUBIO HI I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS AS
ZERO ON THE URGENCY HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS IT ZERO ON
THE MEASURE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING TO FOLLOW. ONE THREE
SIX. NIELSEN. I RUBIO. I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM. ONE THREE SEVEN. PAN
YOUR BRIVIO I STERN. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY OZ THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING TO FOLLOW ONE THREE
EIGHT. RUBIO I STERN. FIVE
THIRTY NINE AM NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES DOWN FILE ITEM.
ONE FOUR SIX. RUBIO I STERN ALL
EYES THIRTY NINE KNOWS IT ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
FOLLOWING A. ONE FOUR EIGHT.
ATKINS CAVALLERO I RUBIO I
STERN. BUYS THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FALL I
DON'T ONE FIVE SIX. ATKINS I
CABRERA I WEST SO. FIVE RUBIO I
STERN HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS
OF IS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
I REMEMBER SWIMMING IN. ONE
FIVE SEVEN FIVE NINE ONE FIVE
SEVEN. ATKINS I OR JUST. GROVE
HER TADO. MELINDA'S NO RUBIO I
STERN. AUGUST THIRD TWENTY NINE
KNOWS SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MEMBERS MOVING TO FOLLOW
ITEM ONE FIVE EIGHT. ATKINS I
PORCHES. DALLY EGGMAN. I GROVE.
MELINDA'S RUBIO I STERN. ALL
EYES THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. DOWN TO ON FILE
I DON'T ONE FIVE NINE. BABIES
GORGEOUS. VALLEY. JONES I.
RUBIO HI STERN. HIGHS THIRTY
FIVE MILLS WON THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING TO FALL IN
ONE SIX FIVE. GLAZER HER TADO.
RUBIO STERN. FIVE TWENTY SIX
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS MOVING A FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVEN THREE. BABIES I DALLY.
GROVE. NIELSEN OVER. HI I RUBIO.
HI STERN. GROSS MEMBERS OR
PROVIDE. ALL EYES THIRTY EIGHT
OUR CURRENT. BRAVO TO. I HAVE
TO CALL. DALLY I STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM ONE NINE TWO. ATKINS
I DIED. I. ZERO FIVE STERN.
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY ODDS THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE MEASURE
PROCESS NOW MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEMS. TO TEN. MELINDA'S. RUBIO
I STERN. FIVE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS
FOR THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW THE
FILE ITEM. TWO THREE ONE. ALAN
I HER TADO. RUBIO. I STERN.
HIGHS PLEASE GO OUT TO MEMBERS
HER TADO I STERN. AUGUST THIRTY
ONE KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FOLLOW.
TWO THREE EIGHT. RUBIO I STERN
ALL EYES THIRTY KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
MOVING TO FALL ITEM TWO FOR
FOUR. MAN NEWMAN. MAN I. NEWMAN
I. RUBIO I STERN. FIVE THIRTY
KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING TO TWO FIVE ONE.
FAITH. EIGHT FIVE MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN NO. RUBIO I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
THE MEASURE PASSES. NON MEMBERS
MOVING TO TWO FIVE FIVE. THIS
RECORD AT THE END OF THE- RIGHT
FROM. THE ROAD THE REASON IS
THAT RIGHT. I COMMEND. I GROVE.
RUBIO I STERN. A. NO GLOBAL.
FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES WE SUPPORT YOU
KNOW FOR WHAT PURPOSE. MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO MAKE
A MOTION TO RECONSIDER ITEM OF
FILE ITEM TWO TWO FIVE AB SEVEN
TWO THREE- THE BILL STILL NEEDS
SOME CHAPTER IN A MOMENT SO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO THE MOTION TO
RECONSIDER. C. NINE THE
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANITE.
YEAH ALL EYES THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO. NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING.
ALAN SENATOR ALAN. YEAH RIGHT
NOW. NO THIS IS NOT A GOOD TIME
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM TO SIXTY. LIFTING CALL
STILL WE'RE BACK TO LIFTING
COSTS FALLING TO SIXTY RUBIO. I
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY MILLS NINE
THE MASURE PASSES NOW ON. TO
TWO NINE EIGHT. RUBIO I STERN
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ONE
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW THE.
THREE NINETEEN- VIA HI STERN
FIVE THIRTY NINE KNOWS IT ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING.
TO THREE TWENTY ONE. RUBIO HI
STERN HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW THE
THREE TWO TWO WHILE I'M THREE
TWO TWO. RUBIO I STERN. AUGUST
THIRTY SIX KNOWS THREE THE
MERGER PROCESS. NOW MEMBERS.
APOLLO PLACEMENTS- FALSE- FALL
AM. SEVENTEEN ATKINS I BASE.
BACKER. HI PORGES. BY ADAM I
ALLEY. TORONTO I GLAZER I GROVE.
WEST SO. JONES. CAN LONGER. I
MON I MELINDA'S. NIELSEN STERN
WELL. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. BASICS
PORGES. DALLY GROWTH. WEST SO.
I JONES. MELINDA'S NIELSEN
STERN WELL. HIGHS THIRTY DOES
ONE THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. NOW FOLLOWING A
MEETING. EIGHT TRANSACTION
COSTS CUT BY ADAM. I NIELSEN.
BUT SHOW UP BOTH. STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY NO SIX APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING BACK TO
FILE I DON'T WANT TO WAIT FOR.
ALAN. BACKER THE MON. THE NON.
PAN FORTUNE TINO. RALPH IN FACT.
PROPHESY RUBIO. STERN NUMBER.
THE CALL.
YEAH OKAY. YEAH.
I
MEAN THAT'S ANOTHER. OUR
MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS SENATOR
SCANNER ARE YOU PREPARED. THE
THANK YOU- MISTER FOR RESIDENT
MEMBERS THERE'S A RESOLUTION AT
THE DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION
TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
ASSEMBLY TRAILER BILLS TO BE
HEARD REPORTED BY THE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE ON
SEPTEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
YES MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
REACH A RESOLUTION. RESOLVED
THAT JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE BE
DISPENSED WITH AN ORDER THAT
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW. I MAY MEET AND
HEAR ASSEMBLY BILLS. ONE FIFTY
FOUR ONE FIFTY FIVE ONE SIXTY
TO ONE SIXTY THREE ONE SIXTY
FIVE ONE SIXTY SIX ONE SIXTY
SEVEN ONE SIXTY EIGHT ONE SIXTY
NINE ONE SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY
ONE ONE SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVENTY
THREE ONE SEVENTY FOUR ONE
SEVENTY FIVE ONE SEVENTY SIX
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT. AND ONE SEVENTY NINE.
AFTER THE DEADLINE. YOU DON'T
THINK THAT NIELSEN'S GETTING
ENOUGH CENTER NELSON FOR
PURPOSE. THIS PRESIDENT- A.
JACK AT THE REQUEST A NO VOTE.
OUR BUDGET IS GONE FROM THE
SUBLIME TO THE RIDICULOUS WITH
THESE INCESSANT. TRAILER BILLS
WE'RE GONNA APPROACH EIGHTY OR
A HUNDRED THIS YEAR. DON'T GIVE
ME ANY INDICATION THERE'S NOT
FROM SUGAR CANE OR GOING ON IN
THE STROLLER BILLS AND THAT'S
JUST NOT NOT AVAILABLE SENATOR
NELSON- GENOVA. I'M SECTOR
PLEASE CALL ROSE CENTER
SCANNERS ASKING FOR VOTE AND
SENATOR NELSON'S ASKING FOR NO
VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA I ADKINS I BAIT
BAIT NO BACKER I FOR JUST. NO
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I FOR
TEDDY I DALLY NO DODD. HI
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I DROVE. NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. I JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI FLAVA. I THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A CHOKE NO
PAN I FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG. ALL RIGHT I Y. CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL. NOW ALL EYES
THIRTY KNOWS NINE. JOINT RULES
ARE SUSPENDED. SURE SURE. AS A
MEMBER SO I MOVE TO SUSPEND THE
SENATE RULES AS THEY RELATE TO
ASSEMBLY BILLS.
ONE FIFTY FOUR
ONE FIFTY FIVE ONE SIXTY TO ONE
SIXTY THREE ONE SIXTY FIVE ONE
SIXTY SIX ONE SIXTY SEVEN ONE
SIXTY EIGHT ONE SIXTY NINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE ONE
SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVENTY THREE
ONE SEVENTY FOUR ONE SEVENTY
FIVE ONE SEVENTY SIX ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
AND ONE SEVENTY NINE AND I ASK
FOR YOUR- BIBLE. SENATOR NELSON.
WE'VE JUST ADDED NINETEEN I
URGE A NO VOTE. DESERT MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. HERE IN
NINETEEN NINE. HIGHS THIRTY
KNOWS NINE SENATE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. WITHOUT OBJECTION
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE THIRTY
THREE POINT ONE JOINT RULE
SIXTY ONE WILL BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW THE GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE TO MEET
SEPTEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
LIVE TO CALL ON FALL ITEM ONE
ALL. FOUR ALAN I. BACKER. THE
MON. PAN FORTUNE TINO. RUBIO
STERN AMBERG. NIELSEN NO DOUBT
HI. THAT NUMBER HI. FORTUNE
TINO NO. R. S. TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- PLEASE MOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO FORTY THREE.
BUT IN TWO FORTY THREE WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. SECOND PLEASE
MOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
FIFTY THREE THAT'S FILING A
MEMBER THREE FIFTY THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOR TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD TO THE
ACTIVE FILES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH STRESSED. YES WELL NO
CINNABAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE
TO REMOVE FILE NUMBER THREE
NINETY FOUR EIGHTY THIRTEEN
ELEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRE
NUMBER WOULD FROM THE CONSENT
COUNTER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU THAT'S
ONE OF THE SENATORS LAID OFF.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM THREE NINETY
AB TWELVE FIFTEEN BURNER ****
BATH. FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND SEND TO THIRD READING. ALSO
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS FROM SPECIAL CONSENT.
FILE ITEM THREE SIXTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY RODRIGUEZ
FILE ITEM THREE NINETY AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN BURNER ****
BATH. THAT'S ONE OF THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO. QUEST FOR THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
THREE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY.
TWELVE ALL SEVEN FOR SPECIAL
CONSENT FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
JUST ONE OF SENATOR ADMIN. THE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE OH FIVE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE THANK YOU JUST
WANNA CENTER CALM WATER.
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY NINE
SIX TWO FROM SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR TO THIRD READING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU JUST ONE OF
CENTERS SCANNER. AS THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO FIFTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. THIS ONE UNDER STRESS
HERE SENATOR HER TRIAL. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE UPPER PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM THREE EIGHT
ZERO EIGHT B. EIGHT THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER ROBERSON
CONSENT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ADMINS. THAT'S WHEN THE- CENTRE
GLAZIER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
TO- ITEMS I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT FILE INTO SIXTY S.
C. A. FIVE BE MOVED TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. AND- I WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL ON S. B. SIXTY THE
SHORT TERM RENTAL BILL WE
PASSED EARLIER TODAY- THE
MATTER LETTERS BEEN REVIEWED BY
BOTH SIDES. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WHO CENTER A BIRD. IN HIS
PRESENT MEMBERS AT THE REQUEST
THE AUTHOR PLEASE CALL AT ONE
EIGHT ZERO FIVE FIVE PHYLUM
THREE EIGHT SIX AND SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR THUS WE NOTE
SENATOR OUR- S. THAT WE MOVE
SCA TO THE INACTIVE FILE. TESS
WILL NOTE. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MOTIONS AT THIS TIME. HEARING
SOONER OKAY. OUR MEMBERS
REMOVED TO SENATE THIRD READING.
OUR FIRST ITEM UP IS FILE I'M
FORTY SIX SENATOR GLAZER ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THAT I DON'T
HE IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR GLAZER AND
RELATIVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY CLASS OF FOUR
MILLION. FOR SURE CENTER THANK
YOU SO MUCH MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IT'S GREAT TO TAKE A
PAUSE. FOR INTERACTIVE DAY
TODAY TO CONSIDER THIS- THIS
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION- I AM
A PROUD ALUMNI OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
I KNOW THAT MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE.
ARE PROUD ALUMNI AS WELL SENATE
RESOLUTION FORTY FOUR
CELEBRATES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND ITS CLASS OF
FOUR MILLION. THAT'S RIGHT
MEMBERS FOUR MILLION ALUMNI.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THEY ARE SPREAD
ACROSS OUR WONDERFUL WORLD BUT
ABOUT 84% OF THEM REMAIN HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. ONE IN TEN OF
ALL WORKERS IN THE STATE. HOLD
THE CSU DEGREE THEY SHAPE THE
STATE'S FUTURE THROUGH TEACHING
AGRICULTURE BUSINESS AND
SCIENCES. TOGETHER CSU ALUMNI
ARE WORKING AT ALL LEVELS TO
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES GROW
THE ECONOMY AND LEAD CALIFORNIA
TO A BETTER FUTURE. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
ON SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY
FOUR. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
THE RATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
NELSON. YES AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RENDERS ACTUALLY A TRUSTEE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. HE
KNOWS IT WELL. I'M A PRODUCT OF
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
MYSELF. IN FACT MY GRANDFATHER
WAS IN THE FIRST GRADUATING
CLASS OF FRESNO STATE WHICH WAS
THEN CALLED A NORMAL SCHOOL AND
A PLATE ON THE VERY FIRST
BASKETBALL TEAM. THE POINT I'M
MAKING NO ABOUT THE- CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY EAST. DECADES
AGO PRIOR TO THE MASTER PLAN
THEY WERE NOT LOOKED AT THIS
STEP CHILDREN BUT NOT REALLY
FULL PARTNERS THE MASTER PLAN
AND THEN THE MASTER PLAN REVIEW
IN MID EIGHTIES MADE THEM FULL
PARKS. AND AS WELL IN THE
EIGHTIES WE MARK MADE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. FULL
PARTNERS. THE INTEGRITY OF
CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION IS
IN NO SMALL MEASURE THE
PRODUCT. OF THAT MASTER PLAN.
REVIEWED IN THE ASIAN
ORIGINATED BY GOVERNOR PAT
BROWN. IN THE SIXTIES. AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES
HAVE EXPANDED. AND THEY'VE
PROSPERED AND ONE IS GOING TO
BECOME A TECHNICAL UNIVERSITY
AS WELL SHORTLY. INDEED AS WELL
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND THE VALUE.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. TO OUR STATE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. NINETY
NINE CIRCULARS OR CALL CENTER
BACKGROUND. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS A PRESENT MEMBERS I JUST
ALSO LIKE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
CLASS OF FOUR MILLION FOR US C.
ISSUE WE OFTEN HEAR A LOT OF
EXCLAMATIONS ABOUT THE YOU
SEIZE ON THIS FLOOR BUT I WILL
SAY THAT THE C. ISSUE- WE LIKE
TO THINK OF AS THE PEOPLE'S
UNIVERSITY EVERYBODY HAS A
CHANCE AT THE AMERICAN DREAM- I
WOULD ENCOURAGE AND- I VOTE ON
SR FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. UNSEEN ON SENATOR
GLAZER WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE I
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FROM THE NORTH COAST-
THE SENATOR FROM STOCKTON AFTER
THEIR WONDERFUL WORDS I KNOW
THAT SO MANY OF US WOULD NOT BE
HERE ON THIS FLOOR OF THE
SENATE. IF NOT FOR THIS GREAT
TWENTY THREE CAMPUS UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM THEY EDUCATE THE MOST
ETHNICALLY ECONOMICALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY DIVERSE STUDENT
BODY IN THE NATION IS SOMETHING
THAT ALL OF US CAN BE REALLY
PROUD OF AND THE WORK THAT WE
DO HERE IN THE SENATE TO
ADVANCE. THEIR IMPORTANT WORK
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NOT ABOUT. MEMBERS THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ON FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX. HEARING C. NINE
OZ THIRTY NINE A NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. THE MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FOLLOW ITEM
FORTY EIGHT. CENTRE HER TADO
ARE YOU PREPARED SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
FIVE BY SENATOR HER TADO
RELATIVE TO PARK BREAST FEEDING
AWARENESS MONTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SINNER T AUTO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
THIS YEAR FIFTY FIVE WHICH
DECLARES THE MONTH OF AUGUST TO
BE BREAST FEEDING AWARENESS
MONTH BREAST FEEDING IS OFTEN
THE FIRST FOOD SYSTEM THAT.
HUMANS AS BABIES ARE EXPOSED TO
BREASTFEEDING PROVIDES GREAT
ADVANTAGES TO INFANTS INFANTS
WERE PRESSED BUT ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BE CHRONICALLY ILL
EXPERIENCE SUDDEN INFANT DEATH
SYNDROME OR SUFFER FROM ASTHMA
DIABETES AND ALLERGIES. AS
YOU'RE FIFTY FIVE ENCOURAGES
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO WORK
TO. AND FIND WAYS WE CAN BETTER
SUPPORT BREASTFEEDING SERVICES
RECOGNIZES THE HEALTH BENEFITS
TO BOTH MOM AND CHILD AS WELL
AS WORK TO FACILITATE AWARENESS
AND EDUCATED EDUCATION ABOUT
BREAST FEEDING. I THINK AND I
RESPECT LESS RELIABLE. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DESCRIPTION OF
THE DATE ON THIS ITEM. MEMBERS
THIS TO HIS OLD ROLE FOR YOU
KNOW THIS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL FOLLOWED A
FORTY EIGHT. BERING SEA NINE
HOURS THIRTY NINE A NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. ON MEMBERS
REMOVE IT ON THE FILE I'M FORTY
NINE. FOLLOW FORTY NINE SENATOR
MELINDA SHE'S READY SAID MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY SIX
BY SENATOR MELINDA'S RELATIVE
TO BLOOD CANCER AND BLOOD
DONATION AWARENESS CENTER
MELINDA'S. ERROR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT S. C. R. FIFTY SIX
RECOGNIZES THE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER TO BRING AWARENESS TO
BLOOD CANCER LEUKEMIA LYMPHOMA
AND MYELOMA THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
HAS RECOGNIZED CERTAIN CANCERS
INCLUDING MULTIPLE MYELOMA AS
POTENTIALLY CONNECTED TO
EXPOSURE TO AGENT ORANGE. OR
OTHER HERBICIDES INTERVIEWS
DURING MILITARY SERVICE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE BRING AWARENESS TO
BLOOD CANCERS IN ADDITION TO
UNCOMMON BONE MARROW CANCERS
THIS RESOLUTION ADDITIONALLY
DESIGNATES THE FIRST WEEK IN
SEPTEMBER IS BLOOD DONATION
WEEK AND MANY OF US KNOW THAT
WHEN WE DONATE BLOOD WE ARE
POTENTIALLY SAVING A LIFE
SENATORS I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME.
IN SUPPORTING US HERE FIFTY SIX
THANK OU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR DOLLAR. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
SHOULDN'T ARISE- ABOUT TWO
MONTHS AGO I WENT DONATED BLOOD
AND- MMHM HE SAVED THREE LIVES
EVERY TIME YOU DONATE BLOOD AND
I JUST IT'S A GREAT FEELING AND
YOU DON'T KNOW THESE PEOPLE.
THAT YOU ACTUALLY HELP BUT I
WILL SHARE- OBVIOUSLY YOU GIVE
YOUR EMAIL THEY CAN TRACK YOU
AND MY PHONE IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS HAS. EVERY DAY I GET IT A
NOTICE THAT THEY NEED BLOOD AND
SELL MORE DONORS THE BETTER OFF
YOU CAN DO IT ANYWHERE HERE AND
THERE'S MANY PLACES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT IS ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO DONATE BLOOD IF YOU
ARE SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT AFRAID
OF NEEDLES AND- AND CAN DO THAT
BUT- IT'S THIS IS A GREAT
RESOLUTION I STAND. IN SUPPORT
OF IT AND THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
OUT THERE THAT NEED YOUR BLOOD
SO. PLEASE DONATE. THANK YOU
CENTER OFF THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- COLLEGE YOU MAY NOT
KNOW THIS BUT- IN FEBRUARY OF
NINETEEN MY YOUNGER SISTER I
HAD TWO OF THEM PASSED AWAY
FROM MULTIPLE MYELOMA. IT'S A
DEVASTATING DISEASE THAT
DEVASTATED HER SHE WAS IN. ON
THE EAST COAST THE UNIVERSITY
OF MARYLAND I WATCH THE DISEASE
RAVAGE YOUR BODY BUT I THANKED.
EVERY DAY THOSE PEOPLE WHO
DONATED BLOOD AND KEPT HER
ALIVE FOR THE MONTHS THAT WE
WERE ABLE. TO ENJOY HER AND SHE
WAS ABLE TO ENJOY AT LEAST PART
OF HER LIFE SO I URGE SUPPORT
OF THIS PARTICULAR RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
pFIFTY SIX- SINCE JUST ABOUT A
YEAR AGO. MY OWN EXPERIENCE
WITH CO BID I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY OVER THESE LAST
TWELVE MONTHS TO WORK WITH THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS. AND
PERSONALLY DONATE CONVALESCENT
PLASMA FOR THOSE PATIENTS THAT
ARE AT TRYING TO RECOVER FROM
COVE IT AND HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE A PART OF THAT PROGRAM-
BUT- POINTED TO THIS.
RESOLUTION ONE OF MY VERY BEST
FRIENDS IS A MULTIPLE MYELOMA
SURVIVOR- HE'S FIVE YEARS- IN
RECOVERY. SO THAT PUTS HIM IN
ABOUT THE NINETY NINE
PERCENTILE. OF AMERICANS THAT
HAVE RECOVERED FROM MULTIPLE
MYELOMA. AND- GOING TO THAT
PROCESS WITH HIM- FIVE TO SIX
YEARS AGO. IN JUST THE RECOVERY
PROCESS GOING THROUGH. THE STEM
CLL TRANSPLANTS AND THE BLOOD
TRANSFUSIONS. AND EVERYTHING
THAT IT TOOK. TO RECOVER. FROM
THAT- DEADLY DISEASE. AND HIS
SURVIVING. AND THAT TO THE
POINT WHERE NOW HE'S ABLE TO
GET BACK ON HIS MOUNTAIN BIKE.
AND RIDE WITH US- PRETTY
REGULARLY- I ALSO I SUPPORT S.
R. FIFTY SIX. AND ENCOURAGE ALL
OF US WHEN WE'RE ABLE TO DONATE
BLOOD. AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SIGNATURE NO
OKAY- IF THERE'S NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION EVENTS CENTER
MELINDA'S WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I THINK MR PRESIDENT I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES WHO SHARED
SOME VERY THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS
ABOUT THIS LAST YEAR I NOTICED
FOR YOUR IPHONE. MEMBERS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS OR ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS MEASURE. SENIOR HEARING
NINE EYES THIRTY NINE A NOSE
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBERS FROM MOVING ON TO FALL
I AM FIFTY CENTER HER TADO.
SHE'S READY MADAM SECRETARY MAY
RATE. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR FURTADO RELATIVE TO RUN
AWAY AND HOMELESS YOUTH
PREVENTION MONTH SOONER TODDLE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AT ZERO
FIFTY SEVEN PROCLAIMED THE
MONTH OF NOVEMBER AS RUN. RUN
WITH RUNAWAY AND HOMELESS YOUTH
PREVENTION MONTH THIS YEAR
FIFTY SEVEN RECOGNIZES THE NEED
TO TAKE ACTION ON BEHALF. OF
RIGHT AWAY- AND HOMELESS YOUTH
IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN HOMELESS
YOUTH YOUNG PEOPLE AGES TWELVE
TO TWENTY FOUR HAVE THE LEAST
ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL.
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE OFTEN VICTIMS
OF PHYSICAL ABUSE SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND CRIME. THE EXPERIENCE HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES AND DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC OR MORE DIRE NEED
OF YOUTH CENTER CARE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. THEY ARE ALSO
IN NEED OF SERVICES THAT WILL
INCREASE OUR ACCESS TO HYGIENE
FOOD SHOP SHELTER AND SAFETY
IT'S IMPORTANT WE RECOGNIZE THE
NEED FOR INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS
COMMUNITIES BUSINESSES. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE TO
TAKE ACTION ON BEHALF OF
RUNAWAY AND HOMELESS YOUTH IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I BOTH. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN ON THIS TOO IS ALSO FOR
YOU KNOW AND THROW CALLS OR ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ON FOLLOWING HIM
FIFTY. HEARING SEEN NINE OZ
THIRTY NINE. KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE I DON'T FIFTY
ONE CENTER TO HONOR YOUR BACK
UP AND BACK. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RE. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR HER TADO RELATIVE TO
ONE HEALTH DAY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT S. C. R. FIFTY
RECOGNIZE NUMBER THREE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS ONE HEALTH DAY
ONE HEALTH DAY IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT OF
MULTIPLE HEALTH SCIENCE
PROFESSIONS WHICH TOGETHER WITH
THE RELATED DISCIPLINES AND
INSTITUTIONS WORK TO ATTAIN
OPTIMAL HEALTH FOR PEOPLE TO
MYSTIC ANIMALS WILDLIFE PLANTS
IN OUR ENVIRONMENT. THE CDC
ESTIMATES THAT THREE OUT OF
FOUR EMERGING INFECTIOUS
DISEASES AND PEOPLE COME FROM
ANIMALS. AND CURRENTLY THERE
ARE APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION UNDISCOVERED VIRUSES
CIRCULATING IN THE ANIMAL
POPULATION. AT LEAST HALF OF
WHICH HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
SPREAD TO HUMANS. ONE HEALTH
RECOGNIZES THE UNDENIABLE LINK
BETWEEN HUMANS AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT. ONE HEALTH EFFORTS
EDUCATE AND CREATE NETWORKS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH AND WELL BEING
OUTCOMES TO ENVIRONMENTAL
RESILIENCY COLLABORATION. ONE
HEALTH DAY PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EXPERTS IN THE
COMMUNITY TO JOIN IN ONE HEALTH
EDUCATION AND A WARRANT
AWARENESS. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECT CLASS FOR NAVAL. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THE- S. R. S. C. R.
FIFTY EIGHT. HEARING AND SEEING
ON- THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF. SEVENTY NINE ICE THIRTY
NINE. NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM FIFTY TWO. WE HAVE SENATOR
LEMOND SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY MAY READ SENATE
RESOLUTION FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RAMON RELATIVE TO
NEWBORN FALLS AWARENESS WEEK
SINGER LEMAR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES S. R.
FORTY EIGHT PROCLAIMS THE THIRD
WEEK OF SEPTEMBER AS NEWBORN
FALLS AWARENESS WEEK IN ORDER
TO INCREASE THE AWARENESS AND
ACTION ABOUT NEWBORN FALLS AND
DROPS A TWENTY TEN JOINT
COMMISSION JOURNAL AND ON
QUALITY AND PATIENT SAFETY
ESTIMATES THAT 600-200-0600 NEW
BERN FALLS TAKE PLACE PER YEAR
IN THE UNITED STATES. REPORTS
OF NEW BERN FALLS IN HOSPITALS
HAVE INCREASED OVER 6100% IN
THE LAST DECADE IN HOSPITAL
NEWBORN FALL DROP EVENTS WHICH
CAN BE PREVENTED MAY RESULT IN
SERIOUS INJURY TO A NEWBORN AND
CAN CAUSE EMOTIONAL TRAUMA TO
ALL INVOLVED THIS RESOLUTION
INCREASES AWARENESS AND
ENCOURAGES UTILIZATION OF
STANDARDIZED RISK ASSESSMENTS
FOR NEWBORN FALLS UPON HOSPITAL
ADMISSION. IN ADDITION TO A
TRACKING SYSTEM TO MONITOR THE
OCCURRENCE OF NEW BRAUNFELS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR YOU KNOW NATURAL
CALLS OR ANY OBJECTION TO
USING. A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
SR FIVE SR FORTY EIGHT. HEARING
CENA ALL EYES THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM FIFTY
THREE SENATOR LAVE US SHE'S
READIES MADAM SECRETARY MAY
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY
NINE BY SENATOR LEYVA RELATIVE
TO WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY SINGER
LOU. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION
FORTY NINE WHICH RECOGNIZES
AUGUST TWENTY SIXTH AS WOMEN'S
EQUALITY DAY EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
PAST AUGUST TWENTY SIXTH EVERY
DAY IS A GOOD DAY TO TALK ABOUT
WOMEN'S RIGHTS. WOMEN'S
EQUALITY DAY MARKS THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION OFFICIALLY
GRANTING WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE THIS YEAR WILL BE ONE
HUNDRED THIS YEAR WILL BE ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE YEARS SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THAT HISTORIC
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION.
THIS DAY IN HISTORY MARKS A
TURNING POINT IN OUR FIGHT FOR
EQUAL TREATMENT FOR WOMEN AND
WOMEN'S RIGHTS THE DAY
INITIALLY STOOD TO REMEMBER
REMEMBRANCE OF MANY DECADES OF
STRUGGLE BY BRAVE WOMEN WHO
BATTLE FOR SUFFRAGE RIGHTS
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY. THESE WOMEN
EMBARKED ON A SEEMINGLY
IMPOSSIBLE CAMPAIGN FOR WOMEN'S
RIGHTS TO VOTE AND IN THE
PROCESS LAUNCHED A CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT THAT ISSTILL BEING
FOUGHT TODAY. AND CERTAINLY
THEIR HARD FOUGHT SUCCESSES ARE
STILL FELT TODAY AS WOMEN HAVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN MANY OF
THE RIGHTS INCLUDING BELIEVE IT
OR NOT OWNING PROPERTY THE
ABILITY TO DIVORCE ON A BANK A
CALL ACCOUNT AND EVEN THE RIGHT
TO WEAR PANTS. OF COURSE NOT
ALL WOMEN EARNED THE RIGHT TO
VOTE IN NINETEEN TWENTY OTHER
ETHNICITIES AND RACES HAD TO
WAIT SEVERAL MORE DECADES TO
GAIN FULL VOTING RIGHTS BLACK
WOMEN HAD TO WAIT UNTIL
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE. A PASSAGE
OF THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT AND
LATINA WOMEN HAD TO WAIT UNTIL
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE EXTENSION
OF THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT. THE
POLITICAL CLIMATE OF THE LAST
FEW YEARS HAS CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED. THAT WE HAVE MUCH
WORK TO DO TO ENSURE THAT ALL
WOMEN TRULY HAVE AN EQUAL RIGHT
TO VOTE. CERTAINLY THE PASSAGE
OF THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WAS
A CRUCIAL STEP FORWARD IN OUR
COUNTRY'S HISTORY. I ASK THAT
EVERYONE TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT A SIGNIFICANT
POINT IN HISTORY. ACCOMPLISHED
BY WOMEN WHO ARE NOT AFRAID TO
CHALLENGE THE RULES FOR THE
STATUS QUO. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HERE IN CHINO AND MEMBERS THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU KNOW AND
THROW CALL IS THERE ANY.
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON SR FORTY NINE.
HERE IN C. NINE. ALL EYES
THIRTY NINE MILLS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR
SENATOR CAFIERO. SHE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY MARY. SENATE
RESOLUTION FIFTY BY SENATOR
COVER EITHER RELATIVE TO
PROBATION SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT S. R.
FIFTY WHICH DECLARES JULY
EIGHTEENTH TO JULY TWENTY
FOURTH AS PROBATION SERVICES
WEEK. THIS RESOLUTION
ACKNOWLEDGES THE CRITICAL ROLE
THAT PROBATION OFFICERS PLAY TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES AND STATE
SAFE. PROBATION IS A COST
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION THAT AIMS TO
REPAIR REHABILITATE JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS OUTSIDE OF
THE CUSTODIAL SETTING.
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ARE THE
NEXUS OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM THE
COMBINED EFFORTS CLOSE THE GAP
BETWEEN RESOURCES FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SCHOOLS CRIME SURVIVOR
ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS AND
THE LARGER COMMUNITY. PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS RECOGNIZE THAT
SAFETY IN REAL REHABILITATION
ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
THROUGH AN EQUITY FOCUSED LENS
PROBATION PROFESSIONALS BIND
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ENHANCE
COMMUNITY SAFETY AND ENCOURAGE
A PRODUCTIVE ADJUSTMENT AND
TRANSITION. BACK INTO SOCIETY
PROBATION PROFESSIONALS ARE
TRAINED EXPERTS PREPARED TO
MANAGE THE TRAUMA AND OTHER
DIVERSE NEEDS OF THE POPULATION
THAT THEY SERVE THEIR EXPERTISE
EXPERTISE. FACILITATES
COLLABORATIVE COMMUNITY
SOLUTIONS FOR THESE REASONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY. THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCO THREAD ON THIS ITEM
SENATOR NELSON. AT PRESENT
LADIES DOWN THE SENATE YOU KNOW
SADLY MOST CALIFORNIANS DO NOT
EVEN HAVE ANY CONCEPT OF WHAT
PROBATION IS ALL ABOUT. AND
IT'S IMPACT AND ITS IMPACT IS
IN THE ONLY INCREASED POST.
REFORM OF THE PAROLE SYSTEM
THERE'S PRETTY MUCH NOT PAROLE
ANYMORE. WHICH MOSTLY MEANS
THAT INDIVIDUALS COMING BACK
INTO SOCIETY DO NOT HAVE ANY
SUPERVISION DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO REHABILITATIVE SERVICES BUT
UNDER PROBATION THEY WILL. AND
THERE IS THAT PAROLE OR
PROBATION OFFICER WHO WILL HELP
ASSIST THEM DAILY. ALMOST
FRENCH STAYING WITH THEIR
PROGRAM SO THAT THEY DO
REINTEGRATE IT IS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO INCARCERATION
IT'S LONG BEEN IN PLACE IT DOES
WORK AND THESE UNSUNG WARRIORS
OUT THERE ARE SERVING THE
PUBLIC PUBLIC SAFETY BUT THE
SIMULTANEOUSLY DOING MORALS OF
GOOD FOR INDIVIDUALS GETTING
THEM BACK TO BE GAINFULLY
PARTICIPANTS IN SOCIETY. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
THE RATE ON THIS ITEM. HERE IN
CHINO AND SINNER COPIER WHICH
ARTICLES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE OKAY THIS ITEM AS
WELL AS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU KNOW
AND THROW CALLS OR ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL HERE SCENE NINE HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW ON TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY SIX SENATOR TO
ROSWELL. SHE'S READY MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR DURAZO RELATIVE TO PAIN
AWARENESS MONTH AND WOMEN IN
PAIN AWARENESS DAY SENATOR ALSO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES THE
MILLIONS LIVING CHRONIC AND
ACUTE PAIN AND THE DEBILITATING
IMPACTS IT HAS ON THEIR LIVES.
BY DECLARING SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS PAIN AWARENESS
MONTH. IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
FOURTH AS WOMEN IN PAIN
AWARENESS DAY. MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED MILLION AMERICANS LIVE
WITH CHRONIC PAIN AND NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE MILLION AMERICANS
SUFFER FROM ACUTE PAIN EACH
YEAR. ALTHOUGH MEDICAL
KNOWLEDGE AND TECHNOLOGY DOES
EXIST MOST PAIN GOES UNTREATED.
UNDERTREATED OR IMPROPERLY
TREATED LEAVING PEOPLE ILL
INFORMED ABOUT EFFECTIVE PAIN
ASSESSMENT AND MANAGEMENT. THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF MEDICAL
TREATMENT IS ALSO SOCIALLY
DETRIMENTAL FOR PEOPLE WITH
CHRONIC AND ACUTE PAIN. OFTEN
AS THEY CAN ALSO BE SOCIALLY
STIGMATIZED AND MARGINALIZED
BEING TAKEN AS CRAZY. WOMEN
HAVE A HIGHER PREVALENCE OF
CHRONIC AND ACUTE PAIN
INCLUDING FROM COMPLEX REGIONAL
PAIN SYNDROME AND
OSTEOARTHRITIS BUT- TAKEN LESS
SERIOUSLY THAN THOSE CASES OF
MEN. AS WOMEN ARE PERCEIVED AS
EMOTIONAL PSYCHOLOGICAL OR HER
MONO. INTERN WOMEN HAVE HAD TO
DEVELOP A NUMBER OF COPING
MECHANISMS TO DEAL WITH PAIN
AND THIS MAY CONTRIBUTE TO A
GENERAL PERCEPTION. THAT THEY
CAN ENDEAR MORE PAIN AND THAT
THEIR PAIN DOES NOT NEED TO BE
TAKEN AS SERIOUSLY. THE
CALIFORNIA BASED PARTNERS FOR
UNDERSTANDING PAIN SUPPORTING
THIS RESOLUTION. IS A COALITION
OF PAIN SUFFERERS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND CIVIC LEADERS
INCLUDING THE FOUR GRACE
NONPROFIT. LED IN PART BY
CYNTHIA AND HER HUSBAND JOHN
WHOSE MISSION IS TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING PAIN. THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES THEIR
TIRELESS ADVOCACY TO PROMOTE
PUBLIC AWARENESS TO THE NEED TO
ADDRESS GENDER DISPARITIES IN
PAIN ASSESSMENT AND TREATMENT.
AND THE NEED TO EDUCATE TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA SUFFERING
FROM PAIN I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING ON IT
THIS ITEM AS WELL AS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF. C. NINE HIGHS THIRTY NINE
DOES IT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
CORRECT READ MOVING BACK TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. AND
WE'RE MOVING. TO WE'RE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE
SENATOR. PRESENTED BY SENATOR
ALAN HE'S READY MA'AM SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
PRODUCT SAFETY. CINDERELLA
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THIS
BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE
INCLUSION OF P. FIVE CHEMICALS
IN A WIDE RANGE OF JUVENILE
PRODUCTS SUCH AS SLEEP MATS
NURSING PILLOWS CAR SEATS CRIBS
MATTRESSES. THESE CHEMICALS ARE
USED IN ORDER TO MAKE PRODUCTS-
STEAM OR WATER RESISTANT. BY
THE PRODUCTS AS SHED P. FIVE
CHEMICALS OVER TIME AND THEN
EXPOSE CHILDREN AND PETS IN
ADULTS FOR THAT MATTER TO THE
CHEMICALS- WE NOW KNOW QUITE A
BIT ABOUT THE ADVERSE IMPACTS
THAT THESE P. FIVE CHEMICALS
HAVE. ON HUMAN HEALTH LIVER
DAMAGE INCREASED RISK OF
THYROID. DISEASE DECREASED
ANTIBODY RESPONSE TO VACCINES.
HEALTH IMPACTS CHILDREN
INCLUDED SUPPRESSED IMMUNE
SYSTEM RESPONSE SEVERE KIDNEY
FUNCTION DELAYED ONSET OF
MENSTRUATION. SO THERE THERE IS
RESEARCH TO THAT'S INDICATING
THAT THAT- HEALTH EFFECTS ARE
OCCURRING AT COMMON EXPOSURE
LEVELS IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION AND DTS SEIZED ON
THE PEACE PROCESS HARMFUL.
HEALTH IMPACTS SO THE IDEA HERE
IS THAT WE ARE. RESTRICTING THE
SALE OF SPECIFIC PRODUCTS
CONTAINING P. FAUCET AND THIS
IS THE ONLY WAY TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIAN HAS. ACCESS
TO PRODUCTS THAT DO NOT PRESENT
A DIRE HEALTH THREATS TO THEIR
FAMILIES JUST BY THEIR MERE
PRESENCE IN OUR HOME. RECENT
AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AND
RESPECT RESTAURANT ABOUT. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HERE IN C.
NINE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS. I BASE. BACKER I
PORCHES HI BRADFORD FIVE BY
ADAM I COURTESY I DALLY. DODD
FIVE TORONTO I EXAMINED EYE
LASER EYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. FIVE HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
GLARED. I LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I GO TO A
VOTE HI PAM. HI FOURTEEN TINA.
I ROCK. FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG HI HI WHAT CASKEY
I WINNER. I WILL HI. MMHM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. BASICS I. DALLY I
GROVE I MELINDA'S. STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON CHOOSE. FILE ON ITEM. ONE
SIX ONE. IN SENIOR WINNER HE'S
PREPARE FIRST ASSEMBLYMAN BLOOM
AND SURGERY TERRY YOU MAY READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AN ACT
RELATING TO REAL PROPERTY.
SENATOR WARNER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE- WHICH
WILL INVALIDATE- DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS IN PRIVATE
CONFIDENCE- IF THOSE- DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS DO NOT ALIGN WITH
LOCALLY ADOPTED INTENSITY
RULES. UNTIL THE MID TWENTIETH
CENTURIES THE MID TWENTIETH
CENTURY- BECAUSE AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW- RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS WERE USED AS A TOOL-
TO SEGREGATE AND REDLINE-
NEIGHBORHOODS- COURT DECISIONS
AND ACTS BY THIS LEGISLATURE
HAVE MADE RACIALLYRESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS UNENFORCEABLE.
HOWEVER THESE COVENANTS OFTEN
CONTAIN OTHER VESTIGES OF
DISCRIMINATION SUCH AS LIMITS
ON THE NUMBER AND SIZE OF
UNITS- THEY CAN BE BUILT. ON
THE DENSITY LIMITS WITHIN THESE
COVENANTS ALSO COMPLEX
FREQUENTLY WITH LOCAL ZONING
CODES THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
ALLOW FOR MULTI UNIT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. DESPITE THE
DISCRIMINATORY ORIGIN IN CLEAR
CONFLICT WITH LOCAL ZONING
DENSITY RESTRICTIONS ON HOUSING
COVENANTS REMAIN ENFORCEABLE
AGAINST- FOR EXAMPLE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS. EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE WILL PROVIDE A
PROCESS TO REMOVE RESTRICTIVE
HOUSING COVENANTS AND ENSURE WE
BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE UNITS
WHILE PRESERVING AND
STRENGTHENING LOCAL CONTROL. BY
THIS MEASURE CLARIFIES THAT
DENSITY RESTRICTIONS ON PRIVATE
COVENANTS ARE UNENFORCEABLE
AGAINST A 1100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT UNDER
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS WHO NO LONGER RESIDE
ON THE PROPERTY CANNOT USE
COVENANTS TO CURTAIL MUCH
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION. EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
REMOVE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS AND
OUR EFFORTS TO TACKLE THE
HOUSING CRISIS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. BUT IF
ANY TO SCHEDULE A DEBATE ON
THIS I DON'T SENATOR OUR
CULTURE. MR PRESIDENT OF WHEN
WE HEARD THIS BILL AND
JUDICIARY I HAD A PROBLEM WITH
IT AND I'M RELUCTANTLY GOING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT- YOU KNOW
WE'VE SEEN THESE COMPARISONS TO
TEACH RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS AND
RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
AND IT GIVES ME A FLAVOR OF
HOW. BAD THESE ARE IN WE'RE
GIVING A PATHWAY TO REMOVE
THESE RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS BUT
IT IS SUCH A NARROW NARROW
PATHWAY IT HAS TO BE A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH
RESTRICTED COVENANTS. WOULD
WOULD REMAIN AND I WOULD URGE
THE AUTHOR WHO PLACES WHO HAS
SEVERAL BILLS IN THIS AREA AND
OTHER ADVOCATES WHO ARE
LISTENING TO TEST TO RATHER
THAN ONLY I KNOW THIS THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL ONE AHEAD
ARE A 100% AFFORDABLE BUT IF
THESE ARE REALLY. NOT
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS THAT WE
HAPPEN RESTRICTIONS THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE IN OUR
HOUSING CODES THAT WE SHOULD
WIDEN THAT. ELIGIBILITY TO READ
TO- REMOVE THEM AND I THINK
IT'S UNNECESSARILY RESTRICTED
TO ONLY A HUNDRED PERCENT-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHETHER IT'S
50% OR 25% SO IT'S GREAT
RELUCTANCE BECAUSE I FELT THAT
I NEEDED TO SAY SOMETHING
WALLABY SUPPORTING IT THERE
NEEDS. MORE WORK TO BE DONE IN
THIS ARENA. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING SOONER AND
SOONER WHEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
CAN'T DISAGREE WITH ANYTHING-
THAT THE SENATOR FROM FREMONT
SAID- BUT GOD THE AUTHOR CHOSE
TO FOCUS ON ONE PARTICULAR
ASPECT OF THIS PROBLEM I HOPE
WE CAN BROADEN OUT IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE HIS CONFIDENCE
REALLY ARE NOXIOUS- BUT THAT
BILL BEFORE US TODAY IS WORTHY
OF SUPPORT AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AUTO. AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE I'M ONE SIX
ONE. ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS
I BASE. BACKER PORGES. BRADFORD
I COVER IT OVER ARE YOU%
PROTESTING I DALLY NO DOG. FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN I. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO I JONES
NO CAN LONGER FIVE LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. NO MAN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO ULTRABOOK NO PAN.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO FIVE ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG
ALL RIGHT HI WHITE HOUSE HE- I
WINNER I WILL NO. FOR HIS
SURGERY PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. BASICS NO BACKER I
GLAZER. MAN I STERN. MARCH
TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES NON MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FALL LINE AND ONE
SEVEN ONE SENATOR ALAN FOR A
SIM BLOWN HE'S PREPARED MA'AM
SECRETARY MARY ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AN ACT RELATING TO WATER
QUALITY. ELLEN FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT THIS BILL PROTECTS
PUBLIC HEALTH BY CREATING
UNIFORM SET OF STATEWIDE
MONITORING STANDARDS AND
PROTOCOLS FOR TESTING BACTERIA.
IN HIGH USE FRESH WATER BODIES
SUCH AS LAKES STREAMS AND
RIVERS. IT HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECT FOR HIS FRIEND OF
A- ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING
SCENE NINE MINUTES SECRETARY
YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE HI
BACKER HI FORTUS HI BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON'T HI CORTESE I
DALLY. GOD FIVE TORONTO. I
EGGMAN I BLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
I DROVE. HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI
HER TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. I THE MON I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I UNTIL ABOUT
FIVE PM I PERSON TINA I ROCK HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG I BY CAL SKI. I WINNER I
WILL. HI. I'M SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBER. BALLY
GROVE. STERN. ALL EYES THIRTY
SIX NO ONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FOLLOWING A ONE SEVEN FOUR AS A
JEW AS WELL SENATOR ALAN ARE
YOU PRESENTING MAN ALL RIGHT
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY RE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING.
CINDERELLA HE WAS PRESENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL TAKES A MULTI
FACETED APPROACH TO SET
CALIFORNIA COURSE TOWARD
MEETING ITS GHG EMISSION
REDUCTION TARGETS. BY MAKING
CHANGES. AT THE STATE LOCAL
REGIONAL LEVELS RELATED TO
THREE SEVENTY FIVE SO IT
EXPANDS THE SCOPE OF THE A B.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS A
FRIEDMAN'S BILL FROM BEFORE.
OTHERS TO THEIR- THEIR- STC
REPORT REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
REACH BY NPOS TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND INCLUSION AND
SCS. PROJECTS THAT DIRECTLY
SUPPORT LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
AND COMMUNITIES IT REQUIRES
CITIES AND COUNTIES T REPORT
ON ACTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
TO IMPLEMENT. THEIR REGIONS. R.
S. YES THIS NEW SYSTEM
COMMUNITIES. AND THEN A BECAUSE
IT REVOLVES REQUIRES CALTRANS
TO DEVELOP A PROPOSAL FOR TWO
BICYCLE HIGHWAYS INTO DIFFERENT
METROPOLITAN AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA PRESENT THE PROPOSAL
TO CDC FOR REVIEW. IT
COMPLEMENTS THE- THE GRANT
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN APPROVED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET- UNDER THE
REGIONAL I REALLY ACTUALLY
GRANT PROGRAM FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SDGS IS.
THE AUTHOR'S WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH ALL PARTIES THERE'S NOW NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND I
ASKED HER I WILL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. SHE HEARING TINA AND-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FOLLOWING A ONE SEVEN
FOUR. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BASE NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I HAVE I
EVER. CORTESE I DALLY. NO DODD.
HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN I. LASER
HI CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. HI WEST SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
GLARED I LLEVA HI THE MON. I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A TROUBLED.
THE TROUBLE NO PAN I FORTUNE
TINA I BROUGHT. NO RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I WAKE
OUT SKI I WINNER. I WILL NOW.
I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
OPTION MEMBERS. BY ADAM I. HER
TADO I. STERN MARCH TWENTY NINE
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS NOW IS
THE TIME TO REMOVE ANY ITEM
FROM- CONSENT CALENDAR OR. IS
THERE ANY OTHER MOTIONS. CHERYL
MOAN YOU'RE BEING RECOGNIZED IN
Q. MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THAT WE PULL AB NINE FIVE ITEM
THREE THREE NINE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DUE TO
REQUIRING CAPTURING OUT AND-
THIS ONE NOTE. IS THERE ANY
OTHER ITEMS TO BE REMOVED FROM
OUR AGENDA. SEVENTEEN NINE.
MEMBERS THIS CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS SENATOR IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER BASE
THE DESK CLERK. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS OF THE DESK IS CLEAR
IN THE SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED
ARE WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY
AT TEN AM. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE WILL BE IN I WILL
ADJOURN. WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT TEN AM. THANK YOU.